Hello my friends.
Hello again.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
is brought to you by one 800 flowers,
one 800 flowers.com.
Go there and get yourself some roses.
My friends time is running out.
If you haven't ordered your Valentine's
Day roses,
and if you don't,
you know what happens.
You get looked on disparagingly.
They cast,
they cast blame on you,
they look at you like you have less.
You didn't fulfill your obligation.
He didn't go out and buy roses.
You can use our
deal@oneeighthundredflowers.com
and get 18 beautiful Valentine's roses
for only 29 99 and for just 10 bucks
more,
you get a full two dozen roses plus a
vase.
We're not going to go pretentious today.
We're going to say vase warm machines
here.
I feel weird if I say boss,
he can't find one more beautiful roses
as such amazing prices and they are
absolutely beautiful roses.
We've had nothing but positive feedback
from all the people that have heard this
commercial and used one 800 flowers.com.
It's a great company and this offer from
one 800 flowers.com
ends today,
February twelfth and only while supplies
last.
So if you ordered now before it's too
late,
then you'll,
you'll hook it up because look,
I mean Friday Valentine's dates right
here,
and if you missed the deadline,
you can still place your Valentine's
order by Thursday,
February 13th.
You just gotta hurry,
so go to one 800 flowers.com
from your desktop or mobile device
today.
Click on the radio microphone in the
upper right hand corner and enter in J
R,
e dot.
That's one 800 flowers.com.
Enter J r e dot,
or you can call one 800 flowers and
mention j r e and remember this is the
last day for their special offer.
18 beautiful roses for just 29,
99 for 10 bucks more.
You get a full two dozen,
one 800 flowers.com.
We're also brought to you by
squarespace.
Squarespace with squarespace.
Come a contest and gave away prizes.
It was actually really hard to do
because there were so many good
websites.
Squarespace is a website where anyone
mean even me,
I could go to squarespace and make a
website.
It's that easy.
It's super easy to do.
Just regular drag and drop shit.
You don't have to know anything weird or
funky.
You don't have to know any bizarre
terms.
They make it very easy for you to do.
They have beautiful designs to pretty to
start with and you don't even have to
enter your credit card.
If you go to squarespace.com,
you can sign up,
try it out,
and then if you decide you'd like it and
you're impressed by what you can make,
then you enter your credit card.
They do that because they're extremely
confident in what they're producing.
Squarespace is a beautiful website.
I mean,
the websites that people created,
they were fucking magical man.
That one,
that storm chasers one I've still visit.
I have bookmarked that one just to,
just to check out the storms.
Amazing Shit.
They also have it set up so you can have
an online store,
very easy,
like really quickly to do.
And you also,
if you're a musician or if you,
uh,
make some sort of audio files,
if you have a podcast that someone would
actually pay for 'em,
you could actually sell musical digital
downloads from the website.
Simple drag and drop stuff.
They offer 24 slash seven support.
You cannot go wrong.
Go to squarespace.com.
And for 10 bucks off your for 10 percent
off your first purchase and a free
trial.
Go to squarespace.com.
And enter in the code word Joe.
That's squarespace.com.
Enter in the code word job,
goddammit.
Warm machine.
I forgot to bring your on it.
Shit.
Militia my mail to the last,
uh,
last sponsor is on it,
o n n I t dot if you've never been on it
as essentially a human optimization
website.
The way we sell things out of it,
I just sell everything I use.
If I use kettlebells,
we sell that.
We find good coffee.
We sell that.
If we find good coconut oil,
we,
if we find excellent protein powder,
whatever we find that we feel is
beneficial and has science behind it.
We also post all the science behind it.
We're also doing ongoing studies,
double blind placebo studies on several
different products.
We want to make sure that none of this
is Malarkey,
so go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t
use the Codeword Rogan and save 10
percent off any and all supplements.
We also have a 100 percent money back
guarantee on these supplements.
If you just think it's bullshit,
you don't have to return it,
you get your money back.
We're not trying to rip you off.
We're just trying to sell you shit that
you're going to benefit from it.
Are you going to want to buy again and
the best way to make you want to buy it
again?
Let's make it as even in just clean as
possible.
Hey,
my roommate buys that shit and he came
and afford it.
Shroom tech is awesome.
I haven't tried it yet,
but he,
he buys it and he can't afford it,
so yeah,
I'm pissed that I forgot to bring it for
you because I'm going to try it for
endurance.
There's not.
I mean,
I love alphabet as well,
but for adherence,
shroom tech is fucking,
but I will say that Roger was on Alpha
brain and I still beat him up.
This is true.
That was a good fight for you.
All right.
On a.com
o n n I t use a codeword Rogan save 10
percent off any supplements following
Paul boom war machine is here.
Cue The music.
Real good experience
Joe Rogan podcast.
Ladies and gentlemen,
powerful war machine.
Let's go buddy.
How are you man?
Good man.
I'm happy to be here.
Happy to have you man.
We,
you and I have been friends for a long
time.
Know you from when you first entered
into the UFC and all through your
various legal difficulties in troubles.
We've always remained friendly.
So,
uh,
I was happy to have you on here man.
And sit down and talk to you.
And I think people have a fucked up
opinion of you.
That's,
it's hard to form an opinion on someone
based on them getting arrested based on
internet battle.
No,
Amanda,
I get all the time.
I get.
I get it.
We're all be out somewhere at an after
party and meeting people and they'll be
like,
hey,
you know what man?
Like I feel bad man.
You know,
I'm one of those.
I'm one of those guys that always
talking shit about you online and act.
I feel guilty,
you know,
nobody,
I don't worry about it.
You,
we're just,
just,
right now I'm,
I'm trying to anchor towards Jim and the
new coach or there's Robert Follis and
I'd never met him before.
He's a great guy.
I liked him.
He,
nobody.
When I first got there before I was
coming,
someone said,
hey,
why don't you start coming?
He's like,
oh,
well we'll see about that.
Like,
you know,
I'll give them a trial run,
and like,
you know,
because you believe the rumors in him.
He met me now every day he's like,
I'm so glad to have you here,
man.
You train hard.
You're a good guy.
You know,
like,
but he doesn't know that.
I know that he used to not like me.
No,
but I get a lot of flack for my
shenanigans and uh,
because it's blown out of proportion in
a lot of things,
you know?
Well,
it's definitely,
some of it's blown out of proportion,
but then,
you know,
you actually did some shit.
You did wind up going to jail for
beating the fuck out of.
Some people got a little crazy a few
times,
but I mean that's normal human stuff.
You know,
like everyone gets in fights.
I mean I'm driving here today and an old
lady was flipped me off on the side,
you know,
cutting me off.
You know,
people are violent,
you know,
it's,
it does happen.
It's a natural thing to get into a
fight.
You know,
it does happen,
but I'm,
what I'm saying is like,
it's not just,
you definitely are a good marketer.
You definitely put your shenanigans out
there to get people excited about it and
a lot of talk.
I mean it's,
it works.
You mean your twitter feeds very active,
you know,
whether it's people hating on you or
not.
Yeah.
I have no filter,
you know,
and it works good.
Like people know who I am and I have a
fan fans gives it,
but also I'm,
I'm kind of on the black edge,
but you know what I mean?
Uh,
some people won't touch me.
Yeah,
I'm sure like sponsors and stuff.
Yeah.
That.
Or even if I was in the UFC right now,
I'd be fired everyday probably.
I was thinking that when I started the
blowjob tweet think they would let you
get away with.
I'd be fired every single day.
Why?
Not Really?
In my opinion,
who cares?
As long as you're not hurting anybody.
It's one thing.
We were also talking before the show
started about Tiago Silva.
You where you got a really good point.
Like Tiago Silva should've never left
Brazil.
Yeah.
Because you could act like that out of
Brazil.
Well,
you know what?
Here's the way I see it.
Bring a man from 19 thirties a,
not a criminal,
a regular guy,
you know,
a lawful citizens and let him live
today.
Guess what?
He's gonna go to jail because there's so
many strict laws now and everything's
different,
so you can't.
You can't be raised with one set of
morals and guidelines and then come live
now when you can't do anything and we
don't want to give the wrong impression
about Brazil because I love Brazil and
I'm a.
I'm a huge fan of Brazil.
I think Rio is like one of the greatest
cities in the world,
Annapolis,
but I've never been.
But the bottom line is Brazilian people
didn't more relaxed about the way they
do business.
They're more relaxed about the.
I mean,
they're very aggressive men too.
I mean there's a reason why the UFC and
mma,
like all of it originated Valley Tudo
originated out of Brazil.
Sure.
There was fights going on all over the
world.
There always has been.
But Brazil has a very special
relationship with violence.
It's a third world country.
Yeah.
So,
I mean,
the police,
I don't know if it is anymore.
No,
no.
Uh,
the,
the economy of Brazil has boomed so much
over the last decade.
Apparently they discovered oil offshore
and resale and.
Yeah.
And there's a bunch of other economic
factors that have led their economies
like very strong right now.
It's actually,
they're probably,
you know,
they,
they're probably one of the biggest
growth countries over the past few years
based on the United States is made with
this treatise country of own violence.
Like did a,
like fights when I was in England,
people were getting into bar fights and
the cops came and broke it up.
No one to jail.
It was like,
oh,
Paul daily,
what do you beat that guy up?
And he got what?
What happens if he's not in jail?
Right.
I went to jail.
Who did Paul Bailey daily beat up some
guy in a bar fight.
Remember he lost,
he lost his visa.
He couldn't fight in Bellatore.
Oh,
I didn't know.
That's why he lost his visa and me like,
I got a bar fight with the 300 pound guy
a year in jail.
Four times,
you know,
he's in.
It wasn't his first offense.
He had multiple offenses and no jail
time,
you know.
Well,
you know,
they look at,
you got a hand grenade tattooed on your
neck.
You got,
what does it say on your knuckles?
Dga.
I don't give a fuck.
I mean,
come on man.
Hey,
if,
if I didn't know you,
I would assume like this guys are paid,
but if you watch problem he watched on
youtube the first case.
It's on the screens.
Cameras.
They're my best friends.
Navy seal.
He starts the whole fight.
He beats up everybody.
I don't jump into.
He gets jumped and I'm the only one they
even got arrested.
So you got arrested just because it
would make publicity and I think
because.
All right,
are we going to charge a navy seal that
just won a bronze medal?
Bronze Star or just wild maniac warmer
sheet who did porn and I kicked out of
the use and that is don't give a fuck.
Tattooing.
It's like they're not going to get the
war hero because my friend's mom was
like,
Hey Ryan,
how come John is going to jail?
You did everything.
That's not fair.
And Ryan's like,
we don't know.
You know,
whatever it happens,
you know?
But that's.
Well listen man,
you know,
because I know if you're in the wrong
place,
the wrong time,
anything can happen.
That's why I don't go out anymore.
Do period smart.
I can't.
I can't risk it,
which is smart and we're also not trying
to make light of what happened with
Tiago Silva.
I don't know the specifics.
I don't know the rules.
I don't.
I don't know.
I mean or rather the facts.
I don't know if he had a weapon.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
I don't even remember much different
rumors.
Yeah,
but I liked that guy.
The way he fights.
He's,
he's a bad motherfucker.
He said dangerous too.
It's tough.
But you know what the.
I know the one thing for sure it was a
woman was involved and people go crazy
with their wife,
women's involved so that anyone is
acceptable.
Susceptible to going crazy when the
white one,
the one that loves involved so it
doesn't excuse it,
but who knows what happened,
you know,
who knows?
Yeah.
It's apparently it's his ex wife and I
don't know what the story was,
but apparently there was an armed
standoff that was with the take the
papers and all the press was reporting.
I don't know if there was any weapons
involved.
I really have no idea.
But it sucks,
that guy's gone now,
you know,
he was a great fighter in the UFC there.
He's never going to fight in the UFC
again.
And uh,
it,
it sucks if whatever he did actually
happen,
it sucks way more for the people that
were as victims of,
of course.
But it just sucks that a guy like that,
I can't keep it together,
you know,
especially if you're a fan of the sport
and you're like watching them fight
their guys.
You always know you're going to have a
fun fight with.
That guy was in there.
I was,
I enjoyed watching them because I was.
Yeah,
but that your point about like a guy
like that growing up in Brazil,
you know,
growing up,
kind of wild coming over here and
everybody is so conservative,
so much.
So many laws and so much buttoned down
on behavior.
You read about England to man,
they,
Doug Stanhope has a whole bit about it.
A lot of countries,
man.
I mean a lot of countries fight as long
as it's one on one.
Hey,
that's cool.
You know,
there's no,
nothing can happen,
but America is strict.
It's no joke with that stuff.
Yeah.
It's rarely hear about UFC fighters
getting in fights though.
If you look at,
it's really pretty,
pretty amazing in comparison.
Like,
like,
you know,
Badr Hari that motherfuckers always
getting in trouble,
you know,
which is another terrible situation
because he's like one of the most
exciting kickboxers on the planet.
Love watching that guy fight.
But he's always in trouble.
He,
you know,
he had to go to Morocco for awhile and,
and,
and hide.
And then he came back and he had to deal
with this issue and then a new issue
came up.
Some dude got his legs stomped at a
club.
You know,
I think it happens more than we think.
I think that,
uh,
people don't,
they just get lucky to get away with it.
I'm the worst because I have,
I've had two twins,
tattoos.
I'm screwed.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
Because they're like,
oh,
what happened?
There was a fight.
A guy had a grenade on his neck.
All this,
punch that into the computer.
You know what I'm going to do,
it doesn't matter,
you know,
but uh,
someone else maybe no tattoos.
It was a white guy.
He was kind of most,
I don't know,
unless you,
unless you recognize them,
you know?
Yeah.
And well,
I'm glad you're deciding to stay in now.
I have to keep away.
Jail Sucks.
I'm sure dude was.
I was in the whole,
you know,
it was boring.
Did they put you in solitary while the,
uh,
the first year I did,
my first six months was in the regular
and then uh,
after that I got in an argument with,
with the sergeant and then one of the
cops,
hey man,
that guy's a UFC fighter,
whatever.
If it's a walk my,
he should be,
he shouldn't be in general population.
They put me in the holding the last six
months.
Why?
It's just because you're a UFC there
saying like,
well,
how come I know that he could have
ordered people to attack me or another
inmate?
So he put me in the hole.
Then the second year when I went to
jail,
the whole year in Vegas,
I was in the whole the whole time
because they already knew I wasn't just
stuck me in there.
Wow.
For how long were you in the hall?
The whole year?
The second year.
The whole year by yourself.
What?
You know,
what,
it sounds bad,
but it's kind of better because there's
no chance to get in trouble for me at
least.
I don't know,
like after a whole,
you know,
you get aggravated one day and then
there's those guys in our fake tough
guys and they want to be jerks and
there's always a little politics.
You get in one little fight and next
thing you know,
I'm back in jail for,
for who knows how long,
you know.
So especially depending upon what
happens because I was in jail in San
Diego when I was in the mainland still.
And these guys were playing chess or
pushups and uh,
it was a little Asian guy looked at him.
He was actually from mom,
Burma.
Nice old man.
He was only in there because him and he
had a wife and three kids and a tow
truck driver was towing his car and he
was like,
no,
no.
Try and stop them until the car.
He pushed the driver so they put them in
jail for assault.
Right.
While she was in there,
he's playing chess with a,
with another guy and they bet 100
pushups.
The Burmese guy,
he won and he goes,
Oh,
you pushups pushups?
And the guy's like,
Nah,
I ain't do shit.
And like,
oh no,
it's not fair.
You know,
like what?
What are you gonna do?
And starts punching the Burmese guy.
He hit him like three,
four times in the guy who a,
he closed his eyes,
one overhand right,
knocked the guy out,
the guy died,
the guy fell down,
hit his head.
They charged him with.
They charged him with murder and it's on
camera like,
you know damn well that was held fence
charged him with murder.
I don't know what happened to that guy
he was in.
He was in when I saw him in the hole,
he was there every day meditating.
He was the nicest old,
like he was probably like 45,
such a nice guy and that's a sad,
sad story,
you know,
and like,
and you know that that can happen.
And then he's,
he's,
you know,
he's Buddhist.
So he's brainwashed.
This is my Karma.
It's okay.
This is the plan for Godly accepting it,
man.
This is bullshit man.
Like I felt so bad.
It made me want to cry.
I felt bad for that guy.
Yeah.
There should be room in the system for
reason.
Like with a guy like that.
It should be a guy like that.
You should be able to pull the guy side
and go,
what?
Tell me what happened,
man.
What's your version of the story?
See that?
And they should be like this.
No,
just don't do this again.
And we're cool.
You just don't hit anybody,
you know,
call the authorities if you have to toe,
toe,
toe touch people.
And the guy would probably be like,
it'll never happen again.
And then you're good.
You don't have to put a guy like that in
a cage.
Well,
you know,
I was reading,
reading like all these surveys and stuff
and articles,
but they were saying that like we,
we have more people in jail than any
country by far by far.
Like we incarcerate people five times
more than England and then end a second,
second place.
We have more prisoners in California and
the whole country of Canada and the
crime rates are the same.
So why is everyone in jail?
You know,
I don't understand it.
It's a business,
but will,
that is the thing that is,
that's a crazy thing to admit and it's a
crazy thing to talk about because most
people,
it sounds so unreasonable.
It sounds like conspiracy theory.
It sounds like you're saying that.
Oh,
I can George Bush plan nine slash 11 and
almost sounds the same thing.
The prisons,
they make profit off of putting people
in jail.
What do you want to charge me for a
stamped envelope?
It was like eighty nine cents for
stamped envelope.
Do stats forty four cents.
And how much does the envelope?
They're taxed you and everything.
Everything's taxed a lot.
It's like selling drugs better than
drugs.
Well,
that's just what's going on for that,
but the actually the private prisons are
getting paid.
You get paid by the government,
by the government to the amount of
prisoners that they have is directly
proportionate to what they get paid.
Yeah.
And then I was reading,
um,
that's crazy.
I was reading an old stats,
right?
So they said,
okay,
a,
a year in jail,
cost to the state,
$55,000
something dollars for a year,
right.
A year.
And um,
uh,
what's called house arrest costs $5,000.
House arrest your half is likely to
receive,
to do new crime.
Right.
So they know that it's a fact.
So why wouldn't you put the gun on house
arrest if it's only for a year and save
space in jail,
you know,
because,
because you know,
what happens,
is that a year in jail,
it was like,
oh,
it's only a year.
Yeah.
But guess what,
you lost your job.
You lost your credit.
He lost her house,
she lost her car.
So you come out with nothing and then
you're like,
all right man,
I wanted to do good,
but I'm going to do one more crime to
get some money and then I'll.
Then I'll be straight again.
But when you on house arrest,
it's like a year.
You're still jail.
You can't do nothing.
Fun.
Jail to work or no home work,
home to work.
But at the end of that year you didn't
lose your credit.
You didn't lose your house,
you didn't lose your car.
So you're like,
fuck,
I don't want to get in trouble again.
And,
but you,
you don't have to start from zero.
You still where you were,
you know,
but the government doesn't get paid when
you under house arrest,
25 grand,
you know,
instead of 55.
But it should work on what works better,
you know,
I don't know man.
It was jacked up system that was in
there.
Well it's,
it's,
it's for profit system and any for
profit system becomes an organism.
An organism is protect themselves.
And that's what they do.
I mean,
when you find out that prison guards
lobby and the prison guard unions and
they lobby to make sure that certain
drug laws are in place,
they want certain drug laws in place to
ensure that there's a certain amount of
prisoners.
That's crazy,
man.
That's slavery.
That is,
that is fucking slave.
It is dude.
And,
and just like the same thing all across
the,
you know,
the inner cities,
they're canceling afterschool programs
and,
and all this stuff and they're building
more juvenile halls.
What a coincidence.
So you're going to fuck in these inner
city kids.
They're going to,
they're going to gang bang or they're
gonna play sports.
You know what I mean?
That's a lot.
You hear the stories of these kids and
why I play sports,
stay out of trouble.
Well now there's no sports.
When I'm a gang,
Bang,
now there's more juvenile halls and they
want that.
It's fucked up,
man.
Right?
If you were,
if you were trying to follow a
conspiracy,
that would be the exact correct thing to
do to make sure there's more crime.
If you were going to try to prevent
crime,
save lives,
you would do the exact opposite thing.
You wouldn't spend the money on juvenile
halls.
He had spent it on community centers.
You spend it on counselors spending on
people.
Look,
I saw your story on pellets about your
father dying when you were young and I
grew up without my dad.
I haven't spoken to my dad since I was
seven and I think that um,
a lot of young men,
especially growing up without any sort
of father figure,
I can get it into a fuck load of
trouble.
You can get so distorted and twisted.
It's like one of the easiest ways for a
young man grew up fucked up to not have
an example for sure.
We somehow or another we need,
we,
we like identifying,
we sort of like,
we connect with these examples.
Positive examples or negative examples.
Yeah.
And there's also the issue that a lot of
people deal with where,
you know,
yeah,
they're fucked up.
Yeah.
They're in trouble yet either.
But they grew up in a piece of shit
household.
They grew up with an asshole for a dad.
They know we're not all starting from
scratch,
like everybody's not starting on the
same level.
Some people start the game at fucking
homebase.
They're already done their one.
Their parents are rich,
everyone's friendly,
they're done.
And some people from the jump.
Your life has challenged from the jump.
It's this food,
there's poverty,
there's a,
there's a salt,
there's all sorts of shit that you're
dealing with in your house on a regular
basis.
Like,
you know,
people say that,
I'm,
I'm a maniac,
right?
I'm more out there than most people.
But like,
I mean,
I don't like to complain about my life,
but for I turned out pretty good for
considering,
you know what I mean?
And if it wasn't for me finding an
outlet and weight lifting and sports and
all that stuff,
I would have been a maniac.
Well,
for sure,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean,
because you,
you,
you know,
you went through a lot of crazy shit for
sure,
but you've always been a good dude to
talk to and that's one of the reasons
why I wanted to have you on the podcast
because that's where I think that people
get the wrong impression of you.
It's like a lot of people in the same
circumstances have,
you would have turned out even worse and
that's the reality of life about knots.
We don't start off in the same place.
We don't even know what.
I was actually on a pretty good track.
My Dad died when I was 13.
I gave him CPR.
He died,
right?
So I went to live with my mom and she
was a drug addict and my step dad's a
drug addict.
The losers,
right?
It was a mess and I had no rules,
man.
I could do anything.
I wanted no rules,
but I want.
I found a gym I went to.
It was a little hole in the wall.
Jim's called mips gym and seeing value.
That's where I grew up,
but it was all like cops and
firefighters and ex military.
And there's an old crusty navy seal,
his name's Jim Taylor.
He was like 55 x Vietnam Guy.
Right.
And he came be.
He became kind of like my dad.
So I was actually,
I pictured when I was in,
I was Jackson.
I was a kid bro.
Like I was like this in high school
because I lifted weights,
I played sports,
I had all a's and b's,
you know,
I didn't get into.
I got in fights,
but that was it.
All good grades a all always sports.
I want to be a navy seal.
I went to the citadel for college.
I was a biology major and now you know,
I was doing everything good now sucked
it up.
I did everything right.
And then after my sophomore year I go to
the guidance counselor's office and
they're like,
hey,
you go with $15,000
from,
from this year.
I was like,
wow.
My mom gets my dad's pension.
He was a cop.
They get that money every month.
It turns out my mom spent all the money
on drugs that's been on drugs and my
stepdad's attorney,
because he did have a fraud case,
right?
So as,
hey,
they said,
well,
the navy wanted to give me a scholarship
for my last few years and commissioned
me afterwards,
but they weren't going to back pay what
I already over the 15 grand.
Right.
So they said we gotta either you've got
to pay this or we got to freeze your
credits.
And,
and I,
I couldn't even transfer my credits.
So I did.
I went into meltdown psychomotor because
I mean I sucked it up all that time and
like didn't drink,
didn't do drugs,
trained,
did community service,
all that stuff.
Good grades.
And I went home,
dude.
And I beat my stepdad almost to death.
Almost killed him.
I beat him bad,
like there's blood on the ceiling.
I smacked him so bad.
And then like,
then I got arrested for like mayhem,
attempted murder,
all this stuff because I beat him so
bad.
But I told the cop straight up,
I say,
man,
I said,
I told them.
The truth is my dad was an lapd cop.
I said he died and I was 13.
I started freaking busted my ass,
went to a military college of citadel.
I have all a's and b's,
biology major.
These fuckers spend my dad's money on
drugs.
You know what I mean?
I came home and I asked him why he did
it and we got in a fight and I said I
couldn't stop eating them.
That's what happened,
you know,
and the cop was there.
Sounds like self defense to me.
Saved my ass.
I would have been when you were 17 that
then I was 20 or 20 points you.
I'm sorry.
You were,
you were,
you were when you went to college,
you were 17 or 18?
I was 18 when I went to freshman year.
So we use,
we stand at home during this time or
Carolina at college,
but I'll come back to summers.
So they were out here?
Yeah,
they're out here in Simi Valley.
So you had no idea that they were
spending your money?
They were paying for the
tuition
for sure.
What happened was when I was,
my dad died,
we all got his money every month after
that when we were kids.
When I turned 18 kid in my name,
so my freshman year I paid the bills,
but it's a base.
It's like a college,
You can't,
you can't really.
It's hard to handle the bills.
Say Mama,
I'm going to put it back into your name
because you know,
just send the check every month.
Oh boy.
She fucked me over.
You know what I mean?
So I got out,
I was so pissed and I went,
I just went berserk mode.
I beat him up,
got in trouble,
and then that's when I packed my bags.
I moved to San Diego,
I went to the lion's den.
I said,
hey,
can I say I want to try out for the for
you guys as team?
And he's like,
you,
you know,
I heard they have tryouts.
Tells Tony Glendo days running.
Yeah.
Well Ken was there,
Tony Vernon,
white,
all those guys.
They said,
well the next trial is now for three
months.
So I got a job.
I actually,
I got a job at a strip club,
pure platinum with a fake id.
I was only 20 and I had a 21 year Id.
I got a job,
was bounced down the Strip club and I
was just going to bally's and running
and lifting weights.
I don't know really how to train really,
you know what I mean?
And I went and tried out for the team
and I made the team and that's how I
started fighting.
Really?
Wow.
So you basically,
you were an angry dude but you were
keeping it together and trying to do
good and trying to stay positive and
this one event sent you into this
fucking crazy spiral because that
happened.
And then um,
actually when I first got home I still
sucked it up.
I didn't beat him up yet.
I got home and I was just like,
furious.
And I was like trying to figure out a
solution.
Right.
And actually,
uh,
my,
my brother's Po was,
he was on probation for,
for weed.
My little brother,
he came to the house and he's like,
hey,
we're sharing a room because I want to
ask you some questions.
He's like,
is this yours?
Is his.
I said,
that's mine.
That's mine.
And there was like a plate with a knife
on it,
like a kitchen plate was death.
And I said,
I want to do this.
Almost somebody was eating due to sign
knife.
I was like,
it's my house was eating.
He goes,
all right.
And like,
and the cop goes,
uh,
you kind of have an attitude.
I said,
yeah man,
I,
I don't really want to talk to right
now.
You know what I mean?
What in your house?
Yeah,
what do you guys want?
I'm not on probation.
My brother is because you don't.
I'm gonna Search you.
I was like,
no,
you're not.
He's like,
yeah,
animals are not me,
bro.
And he grabbed my wrist and I pull my
wrist back and the all four jumped on me
did.
He jumped on me Bro.
And I was like holding my hands together
and they couldn't get me down.
They're pissed because I was jack that I
was struggling.
I could wrestle too,
you know,
and the dog down and I was like,
are you guys fucking serious?
You have to fucking pussies.
They're fucking pitch.
Just clench your hands.
Gave me their fucking freaking out.
And it was wood floor and it was
slippery.
Take down defense for dudes.
Even if they suck at wrestling because
they are counteracting each other.
Um,
you know,
there's like,
you know what I mean?
They're helping me and really so
funding.
I slipped and as you can have them,
you want to fucking.
They cuffed me and then they beat the
fuck out of me.
Dude.
Once they cuffed to beat the shit,
I'm was like,
what are you guys doing?
That's Jonathan,
not Michael.
So
they knew I wasn't in,
so I still think nothing's going to
happen.
They're gonna let me right,
fuck no.
They arrested me for assault.
Two counts of assault on a police
officer resisting arrest.
They,
their story was that I came downstairs
and said,
I'm Michael Down the Po knows my
brother.
Like they lied.
Right.
So they scared me.
They scared me.
A didn't,
Diego's,
Oh,
we'll just plead guilty to a misdemeanor
resisting arrest and nothing will
happen.
I said,
fine,
I'm fuck you.
Whatever.
I did it and then I get home and then I
was just like,
good explore.
The whole time.
My Dad was a cop.
I was raised Republican.
Cops are good governments.
Good.
I wanted to be a navy seal.
I want to.
I love the country.
I said,
I never believed stories.
The cops fuck you up.
I thought my dad said,
that's a lie.
You know what I mean?
That's a lie.
The cops are the good guys.
My whole life is flipped upside down.
I said,
fuck this,
and I beat my step.
Dad's death.
That's what I find.
That's what I it the cops.
It was dirty cops for she to beat your
Stepdad's head and that,
that,
that right there changed me.
If you,
if I knew myself as a kid,
I would hate myself.
I'll be like,
well,
she's a piece of shit.
He's an antiemetic.
I was so down for the country down for
cops done for
if you knew yourself when you were 18
years old,
when you knew you knew yourself of
today.
Oh,
it hit me.
Wow.
I think I'm a piece of shit.
You know what I mean?
Wow.
I totally changed my whole thing,
but isn't that incredible that just a
few events like that can.
Especially when you're a young man can
just steer your life in one way or
another can stick to you.
Are you down a road?
Like if you,
if you're,
if you'd never put that money in your
mom's name and you continued paying your
bills and you dealt with all your
tuition,
who knows?
You would have probably been a fucking
war hero or something.
I'd be,
I'd be Brian,
Stan,
you know,
one of those characters.
I'd be super brainwashed.
I was maybe,
maybe not.
I mean,
you know,
as you get older,
you're,
you're smart.
You're not.
You want to start questioning shit.
My two best friends are seals,
right?
There's got out.
But like,
uh,
they,
they question,
you know what I mean?
Like they're not the same.
When they came in,
there were not.
It's kind of bullshit.
I have friends who not only served but
went on and worked for Blackwater and
they question everything they do.
They do for the money.
Well,
they do it because look,
my buddy who went to black powder,
he was getting like 30 grand a month
started.
Jim bought a mustang
boy fucking.
He was guarding the oil ships for the
pirates,
so it was four be four x.
He was on the ship and the pirates come
and they blast them doing.
Yeah.
I see videos on the head.
Cam said,
well,
the crazy thing about the pirate
situation and people don't even know why
those poor poor fucking people because
another fucked up situation.
Somalia had never had a history of
violence like that.
They weren't like people that would
kidnap.
They were doing it because they were
kidnapping these European captains of
these boats that were dumping toxic
waste off their shores.
So is that why your fishermen to
Somalians were fishermen and so all
these fish were dying and they're
fucking starving and then people getting
birth defects.
All this pollution in the water,
the fish are polluted.
It's like really bad.
They dumped nuclear waste often,
so the Somalian start kidnap the
captains to these boats and holding them
ransom for crimes against the
environment.
So when they did that,
they were making millions of dollars so
then they'd be like,
fuck fishing,
fishing.
But they're like,
look,
there's no fish left.
I mean the Fisher,
they don't untold tons of toxic waste
off the shore of Somalia.
See,
I didn't know that.
That's supposed to know.
You don't even know all of these things.
We think we think these assholes are
just.
They're just pirates.
They want to.
You know what I mean?
I don't know the story of my friends
don't know the story.
I bet my name is Cielo friends.
I don't know if they had that in that
Tom Hanks movie.
I didn't see that movie,
but that's an important part of why
those fucking deal.
It's not like you just fell upon a
village of [inaudible] and they all
machine guns.
They're hopping into boats now.
These poor fishermen for thousands of
years and we ruined their fish in like
that for thousands of years.
These people live the exact same way.
Fishing,
living off the land,
having a good time,
you know,
getting by and all of a sudden some
assets to dunk nuclear waste off duty.
I said,
I always say technology is the great
evil dude.
Well,
some humans are evil.
Who's technology mean before technology?
You know,
Gingiss con was evil as fuck.
I mean there was,
there was people that would be,
I guess both our technology.
There's technology for back then people
were,
you know,
do we have a great propensity for evil
and for good,
but I mean now,
I mean like as far as like the world
was.
I mean as it was all of history as far
as in the last hundred years with
technology,
we polluted.
Everything's fucked up.
That is true.
You know what I mean?
So I'm seeing that technology.
I know in my.
My thing is,
is that because I believe that the
Michigan Lincoln Shit,
all that shit was really alien to know.
Do you really believe that?
I've written.
I read the best books.
I've read a ball to the twelfth plants
series.
Yeah,
yeah.
Zechariah stitching fucking good at it.
Makes more sense than anything else
you've got to go to.
Situation is wrong.
Dot Com and then they prove them wrong
thing.
Well,
the.
Here's the deal.
A lot of what he,
based on his,
his interpretation of some really
bizarre old tax,
but what's really incredible about the
Sumerians was how much they absolutely
did know.
There was many,
many first came out of that area as far
as we know.
First we'll first written language,
first agriculture,
first,
mathematics,
first written language that we're aware
of it,
and they had a Godfrey's thing.
That's why I was thinking it made sense
that,
Oh God,
for math,
because that was the elite and the
thought of math.
You know what I mean?
The God for fucking I'll culture.
Well,
that guy showed me how to fucking make a
farm.
It could be.
We had no way to prove either way,
but I figured like,
look at this,
look at the.
Look at the earth.
We're the only thing that doesn't belong
here.
We're the only thing on this earth that
doesn't live on the earth,
were wearing clothes with live in the
buildings.
Everything else is living on it for
real.
We're all like,
we're like,
we don't belong here.
Like,
like we're out of place with the only
thing that's out of place.
It's kind of like,
like we're half fucking alien,
half human.
We don't belong here.
You know what I mean?
Like us as dogs,
dogs are like us,
but they live.
They live off the earth.
Yeah.
But you know what I'm saying?
How they're very.
Like,
it could be like me and Shaquille o'neal
are the same species.
We could buy the same woman pregnant.
It doesn't make sense.
You know,
it's like a giraffe and a horse being
able to get a cow pregnant,
you know?
It doesn't make any sense.
Like we don't look anything alike.
They'll bridge it to midget and Michael
Jordan.
They're the same species.
How the fuck is that possible?
That's not the same.
Just like dogs.
Dogs are the only animal that we're
aware of that have that kind of
arrogance that can interbreed like that.
It's,
it's a very strange thing because we
know that dogs were human manipulated
and then the whole argument with people
that were the reason why there's a quote
unquote missing link,
which are I guess apparently when you
talk to people really understand
biology,
there really isn't a missing link.
It's just a matter of the fossil record
been very difficult for all the pieces.
See the fossil record,
the issue with fossils is if you die or
I die right here.
So like say if there's a gas leak in
this building and explode,
we're not gonna leave.
A fossil man has stuck.
It has to be stuck in mud or something.
So it's real hard to make a fossil.
So there's probably.
And not only that,
humans are smart,
so the odds of them getting fossilized
are probably less likely than a dumb
ass.
Buffalo falls into a pit and all his
buddies fall right in after them cause
they're all fucking stupid.
Nobody figures out how to get the book
makes such good sense because it's like
how they said that they came here and we
were like,
the in between links,
like the monkey is Kinda guy like,
well these things were fucking smart,
but they're not smart enough to do what
we would want them to do.
They're kind of,
they're still like animals,
you know,
always put some,
put some our genes and I'm smart and I'm
up.
Well,
you know,
possible.
Who knows?
It's sexy.
It is,
but you know what?
Because you know,
like the Old Testament or the,
all those stories,
if you read them in the terms of not God
but aliens.
That makes way more sense.
Well,
that's the switch and said he's a
nephew,
limb.
He said he got in trouble when he was in
school because he said that their
translations were incorrect.
He said that the Nephilim,
uh,
you know,
they would call them giants amongst men.
He was,
he was saying that isn't,
it isn't the eggs.
The actual translation shouldn't be
those who came down,
meaning those came from above.
And then the Annunaki,
the literal translation.
Apparently as those from heaven to earth
came,
the idea that they came from some guys.
Yeah,
look,
if we put a fucking robot on Mars in
2014 and we could watch realtime video
that moving around,
that's a fact that things up there.
Humans are just one form of
intelligence.
If the universe is filled with
intelligence,
I guarantee you they're going to want to
check out what's on other planets.
Why wouldn't they?
Why wouldn't they send things?
We're trying to go places course and we
would definitely visit if we could,
if we could visit Mars,
we haven't been able to figure out how
to do it yet,
but they're trying to figure it out
there.
We might be 20 years away from a person
going to Mars,
so if that's the case,
why wouldn't someone come from another
planet?
The real problem is nobody agrees with
that.
Guys,
translations.
That's one one problem and the other
problem is that all these people want to
believe in.
It's so bad.
It's so sexy that they don't look it at
it as a.
maybe they gravitate towards it and they
run with it like this is the aliens came
and they work with our
DA.
Are you sure bitch you're not.
You're not sure,
but it makes more sense than the Bible.
It definitely makes more sense to the
Bible,
but it's probably related.
If I could pick,
I'd rather of the Bible to be true.
I want to go to fucking heaven.
Just such thing.
You know what I mean?
I'd rather have that true.
I'd rather have Santa Claus all the
fairytale fairytales.
True,
but I just think it makes more sense if
there's an option Bible aliens.
I'm picking the aliens.
I don't think it's an either or option.
I mean,
first of all,
the real problem with the Bible is like
that telephone game.
You know,
you tell your friends story,
he tells time,
it gets back to you.
It's fucked the stories.
Fuck.
And they told the stories of the Bible
for over a thousand years before they
ever wrote them down.
The oldest version of the Bible they
have is in Aramaic and it's founded in
these,
these clay pots in a place called Qumran
and it's called the Dead Sea Scrolls.
Yes.
That's the oldest version of the Nag.
Hammadi scrolls wherever.
The other ones.
Yeah.
There's,
there's quite a few ancient animal
skins.
Actually.
Even the Samaritans had almost the same
story.
It's just different names.
It's an old story.
From what?
Who's taught,
who taught us that?
Well,
it could be a bunch of different things,
man.
I mean,
you stop and think about the variance in
how far cultures of advanced today.
Like you could today.
You could go to the Amazon and find some
marine forest people that never seen
people.
You show them your watch,
they'd be freaking out.
You show them a laptop,
they think you're a fucking wizard.
I mean,
just think about that today.
But that happened in World War Two,
right?
Yes,
it did.
Island,
they're from,
um,
chariots of the gods,
a Erich von Daniken documentary.
Like we gave them candies and shit.
And like they thought we were a.
and they built fake airplanes.
The worship,
they want us to come back and whenever
he came back and we want to.
God,
that's exactly.
Exactly.
Yeah,
that's exactly what it's like.
I think that if you're a
superintelligent race or a super
intelligent civilization rather,
and you run into someone of your own
race that just happens to be trapped in
the outback of Australia and living off
the land,
they would have no idea that within a
thousand years they had been living like
this.
Which cultures exist in the same static
state for a thousand years all the time,
but look what's happened in this
country.
Just 200 fucking years crazy.
There's no America.
Three hundred years ago it didn't exist.
There was nothing here.
There was no buildings.
There's no roads and in 300 years you
got la,
Chicago,
New Orleans,
and fucking fucking chaos all over the
place.
That's a blip in time.
So for these people living in a static
state for a thousand years,
all of a sudden people come in.
Then they tell stories about these
people.
Those people are fucking alien span.
They came,
they had chariots.
Horses drove them around like when the
ink is first saw,
the uh,
um,
the Spaniards,
they thought they were fucking God's
people on horses.
They thought they were a part of the
horse.
They didn't even know what the fuck was
going on.
They thought it was quite so quantile
returning.
They had no idea was happening.
They were freaking out.
So I think that those stories,
when you,
you,
you're dealing with over a thousand
years of them telling them back and
forth before anybody writes them down.
Then they write them down.
They write them down an era man,
they
write them down in ancient Hebrew and
meech and Hebrew.
They,
they only know like three out of four
words today in ancient Hebrew and
letters were numbers like the word God
and the word love.
They had the same numeric value like
words like war machine would have a
specific numeric value that would not
just represent your name but also like
what you are and like a person who your
lover or your mother would represent.
We have a certain number to it and that
was important in the waist sentence,
was translating information.
They lost all that shit when they
translated it to to Greek,
into Latin,
and they did all that's missing and say
you get this flat interpretation of this
really bizarre,
ancient language.
That was a language that it was also
numbers.
It was a math and a language together.
It's hard for us to even wrap our heads
around,
which is crazy that people fucking
really,
really believing kill for it like they
want to believe because if you don't
believe,
then you have this open ended questions.
Everybody likes to be fucking
comfortable.
I'm pretty wants to retire.
Everybody wants to run the win.
The lottery.
What they don't understand is the
beauty's in the struggle.
The beauty is in the struggle.
Really appreciate life.
You've got to know you're going to die.
You've got to know it could be all over.
That's how you really appreciate it.
That's true.
It's just like fighting,
you know,
like,
uh,
when I was brand new you,
you envision or when I feel like I'm in
Tj fighting in Tijuana,
right?
And like when I be in the UFC was gonna
be this way.
I get to doc and it ain't that way.
It's Tj.
It's the same thing.
It's the same fight,
but just struggle.
It's just dominick Cruz,
you guys live with them,
you know,
he's been wanting buddies all like,
now you're the champion.
He's a champion.
It's not real for him.
Like people that don't know him seeing
me as the champion,
but for him he's still him and like he's
fighting for the belt.
He has the boat but it's not real.
It's like the first time I ever saw like
my meat myself fight in the UFC.
I foughtj rock and I got home and I
googled it or whatever and I found it
and it was like,
it didn't seem right.
Like I was in the,
in there like with Joe Rogan's
interviewed me after the fight,
you know,
it doesn't seem.
It seems like I like photoshop that in
today.
Yeah,
because you're still,
you your.
But now you're seeing you as other
people see you.
Yeah.
So would you envision something in a way
it's going to be in an ever that way?
Well,
isn't that also one of the things that
happens when people start attacking you
online?
It's like people,
they're attacking like a celebrity.
They're attacking adjusted Bieber,
they're attacking whoever the fuck it is
that they see that as the object of
their attention,
but that person who they're attacking,
you don't even know them.
Like you don't know any of these people
and yet they,
they,
they feel,
they feel that you're like a free
target.
They want to kill me,
dude.
People,
hey,
people say fucked up.
Like just like last week,
someone's like,
like,
yeah,
you suck.
And Cpr,
like motherfuckers be referring to my
dad.
I get that all the time.
People say,
I'm like,
dude,
you don't like,
I don't,
I don't get obsessed too long.
Like I almost had to laugh.
Like,
what a fucking Dick.
Like what?
You don't even know.
Why would you say that?
Like that's addicting.
You don't know.
It's the Internet man.
The problem is that people could say
shit the Internet and there's
no social accountability.
Now Accountability and you don't feel
it.
Like if you say something mean to
somebody,
how many.
I can tell you,
me personally,
I've said Shit where I might've been
just joking around,
but I said something mean and then I saw
the look on a person's face and I'm
like,
I'm sorry.
I was just fucking around.
I didn't even mean you don't mean it to
come off that way sometimes,
but you do so when you just get a free
ride and he just,
he's fucking war machine,
second CPR and they send that out there.
It's like,
it's bad for people.
It's unhealthy.
Sucks.
And creates sociopath's.
Yeah.
You know what it's like whenever I go
out,
I've never had one person to be mean to
me.
Of course not.
They're always nice to me and,
and I'm,
I'm,
I'm cool man.
As long as you have to do something dumb
for me to be mad at,
you know what I mean?
I'm cool.
But like,
where are you guys when I'm out,
you guys want to recall it being said to
me when I'm out.
You want to do it on here?
Why do you do that?
You know,
I'm glad because I don't know.
It's probably different people,
but if you met them,
it probably be the same thing,
man.
I mean people are asking me about that
all the time.
Like do you ever get hassled people?
Wanna fight you already?
Never.
People were nice to me everywhere,
everywhere,
everywhere wanting to me,
man,
I'm going to give you a hug.
I'm friend that you know,
and once they realize that,
but it's,
you know,
you're just become an object when you're
on a computer screen or on television
when you're fighting,
you know,
like your focus is guards bullshitted
sort come up with some reason that fight
that you had with Jay rock.
Dude,
that was a important fight for me for
two reasons.
One because I realized how much damage
you can do from the guard with your
elbows.
Me Up,
dude.
That was a,
that was a big moment for me because I
never saw anybody deliver elbows like he
did from the golf.
I don't even know how he practiced that.
I mean I asked them pass tech.
He told me,
he told me that he was like a tire,
like a tire in between his legs.
Like even the Guardian smashing it,
but I mean like,
dude I have this day.
No one's done it like that.
I like that he was good.
Um,
I was dizzy for a concussion for like a
week and half that I thought I was
dizzy.
I believe you,
man.
I mean that that night I had this chick.
Oh she was so hot.
Dudes try and I was going go smash words
at the palms that night and I took her
home board.
I was doing.
I was so dizzy trying to fuck her going
to throw up.
I laid down and I was asked if he did
come and throw up at the same time I
laid down bro.
I was,
hey,
you just got to ride me.
But I couldn't lay flat.
The room was spinning.
Did you call her bro?
Fucking hammered.
You were.
But I had to sit up.
I had to stood up like upright and have
a riding because I laid down the room
was spinning.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
But he jacked me up with those elbows.
Dude.
That was one of the most effective uses
of elbows from the guard.
I've ever seen the only other time I've
seen something really crazy from the
guard looked at as you're Brian Hall.
Stop that dude from his guard on the
last issue,
the last version of tough and you have
to guard.
He was on top.
He got reversed.
He had to do,
I think,
I forget how he got into his car,
but anyway,
in his guard,
knocks the guy out with punches from the
car.
That doesn't seem that crazy.
I've never seen that before.
But that mother fucker hits hard.
But that Jay rock fight was also intense
because you guys were really good
friends.
You guys have become real close in the
house and you were hitting him and then
you were saying,
I'm sorry.
I love you.
I love it.
Yeah,
we were talking.
we talk and during the fight and you
were doing it like a couple feet from me
and I remember thinking like,
Whoa,
this is some heavy shit and I'm trying
to do the commentary.
I would like to have just been able to
just say nothing and just watch it
because it was a great fight.
But it was also like,
there was a crazy interpersonal
situation.
It was weird,
man,
after the fight when you're going to do
me A.
I cried because I was happy.
I cry because I was sad because I ruined
his.
His dreams.
Yeah.
It was genuine.
It was very genuine.
I was like fuck,
like was I want to win it because at the
end of the day is my,
my life has to succeed,
but I don't want to kick with my
friend's dreams.
Like,
you know what I mean?
And that's the hard thing about mma is
that if we were making,
if we're all making maybe with her money
dude,
like oh just go joe,
20 million.
She gives a fuck.
But like when you know that the person
that they lose,
they might not,
they might not have a job anymore.
It's different doing,
you know,
especially if you like the Guy George
said it best,
he said he would never fight a friend.
He said because there's things that he
does to Apollo.
He would never do to a friend.
He said I just couldn't.
I couldn't not do it if I was on top of
him,
I could not deliver elbows to his head.
Concussive damage.
Yeah.
He was just talking about like the
viciousness of dropping elbows on
someone's head.
You just wouldn't do that to your
friend.
You wouldn't be able to do that to your
Yeah.
But more than that,
because I mean,
I spoil my buddies and we'd beat the
shit out of each other.
You know,
there's a little different,
right?
It's different,
but trying to kill him.
It's,
there's,
there's the fee thing in competition
where it's fucking real.
This is real.
This is,
this is not just competing in the gym.
this is ready.
Ready,
go.
Ding.
The bell rings.
The cameras are on you.
There's no take backs.
There's no redos.
The hard part would be,
uh,
would be finishing in front enough ones
that hurt.
Like say if you're going to knock him
out and then that has happened.
Right?
But if you rock him and he's like,
you know,
trying to put them out that,
that'd be like fuck,
you know.
And he's like,
you'd want the rep to stop it.
It'd be different,
you know,
like Mochida Munoz,
perfect example,
real good friends,
Machita head kicks him and moved into
close the show and decided not to.
Whereas anybody else,
he would have hit him with seven punches
before that referee kill mode.
You know,
he gets into those fucking karate
punches.
He throws those rapid fire,
right hands.
Yeah.
Machida's a closer.
And you know,
that was a perfect example of the
difference between fighting a friend.
And he was crazy.
That was crazy.
Head kicked too because he knocked them
out through his.
He had his guard up.
He went through his hand.
Sometimes that's not enough.
Not enough for a head.
There's some power in the dude like that
is so fucking hard.
That's why the Thai guys,
they both hands and away from their
head.
Yeah.
This,
it'll still at the Andrew transfers
through,
through your army.
Is it hard to make that transition
though to the smaller gloves?
Because you know,
the problem with the smaller gloves too
is when dudes try to do like that k one
styled Dutch thing like this.
There's all these openings that don't
exist with those exact.
This is exactly why since two years ago
I refused the spoiler.
Big Loss and I don't do it ever again.
I don't want to do it.
Smart could just be and people say and
dangerous,
man,
I'll tell you what,
watching UFC,
knowing from punches,
it's mostly elbows,
headbutts,
accident needs,
whatever I'm that happens,
but it's rare and they're going all out.
Punches usually don't get cut that much
and in practice I've never cut normal
little gloves.
When you grease your face up to the
fight and fight a lot of grease and they
sell the puffy sparring gloves and I
tell you what mean.
We go hard with those and I've never
been cut,
not cut anybody,
but then when I was sparring j Romley
foster and pure long time ago,
headgear ambig gloves.
I cut the shit out of him.
I just a wild party.
This is what's happening.
If it's gonna happen,
it's gonna happen,
but like you said,
the big loves you can get used to
blocking way differently.
It's a big old thing,
but you can't block that way,
so I don't.
I only probably a little gloves now.
Yeah,
you see that a lot from like the real
high level kickboxer guys.
They'd go into mma when they realized
how many openings are left,
where they're so used to like if you
find like a nicky hold sand in one of
those type guys that like fights,
that classic Amsterdam style,
they,
they have that hands up high,
which is fantastic for kickboxing.
But when guys like that enter to mma
like alister,
like it's.
It's a weird thing because there's all
these openings there now and say,
I think that you want good,
good.
Boxers are,
they can,
they can block always punches.
That was a little bit ain't gonna
Happen.
It's not going it.
And what happens is if your defense,
if you're not comfortable in your
defense,
then it ruined everything because you
start panicking like why am I,
how's it?
How's it hitting me?
You know what I mean?
Such a difference in the impact as well.
If even if you do catch a punch,
like say if you catch a guys right hand
and you know you have it in front of
your face with that little glove,
there's not much protecting.
You enhance that big ass glove.
The boxing glove,
it's like a big pillow hitting you in
the face.
I mean obviously you know,
it's still fucking hurts and dudes get.
But there's such a difference in those
four rounds to eight ounce gloves to an
enormous difference and most of them are
fighting with 10 ounce gloves.
Yeah.
You know,
the last two years,
man,
I don't it,
like right now I could towards him like
tours and they do Tuesday is little
gloves and there's this big lifts.
I don't go to Thursday really.
And they say,
well it's good to do both.
I don't think is good is my opinion,
but I'm stubborn and you know,
that's the way I don't believe in it.
You know,
it's definitely different and it's
interesting to see even though the court
what,
what year you were,
what year was your year of the ultimate
fighter?
Two thousand seven.
Even from 2007 to today,
thinking about how much things have
changed,
there was no we'll kicks back then no
front kicks to the face and what it was
doing.
The karate kids were coming in.
They were starting to now,
so like ufc one people thought quite.
It was disapproved because they got only
one thing.
Then everyone went to like wrestling Jiu
Jitsu and now cried.
He keeps coming back because I figured
if you can box and wrestling Jiu Jitsu
and a cool credit kick acute,
it could work.
You got to mix a little bit of
everything because like even Bruni,
you don't fucking meathead Bruni.
Well last year,
so I'm gonna start doing like shut up
bitch.
I swear dude.
No,
I'm serious dude.
Peter was doing it and he's like,
man,
I think it's good to know.
I just want to like three of those good
kicks.
And I said,
well,
I said,
well it won't hurt,
but you know what I mean.
I know I can't really picture Brian
doing that.
I can picture him doing it.
Could you?
You got a bad ass kicked.
I was watching some videos of you
kicking the bag with St Pierre.
Yeah,
Dude.
I was a kid.
That's all I did was taekwondo,
taekwondo fan type one was all kicks,
kicks,
but the problem was I transitioned into
kickboxing when I was 21 and my fucking
hands were terrible.
I was getting lit up in the gym,
but I just couldn't believe it.
I thought my hands were way better and
then I,
I,
I cut out like maybe 60 percent of all
taekwondo techniques and I concentrated
on like a core fundamental techniques
and started learning how to box and then
I started doing more Tine.
I realized,
oh,
then there's leg kicks.
God Damn it.
It was a.
those are lots of things.
Like everyone was so stubborn.
You can't.
There's good things and everything.
The thing about learning the taekwondo
is you because there's no punches to the
face and there's no leg kicks.
You get really good at doing shit that's
super risky.
If guys are throwing leg kicks and
punches you in the face,
whereas you might not really get good at
those techniques because you wouldn't
put as much care to throw.
Um,
yeah,
exactly.
So you get real good at.
Um,
and then when you learn those other
things,
you already have that crazy dexterity.
You know,
my boy has bad ass kicks at Radcliffe,
the black kid and I'm living here.
Yeah.
He has nasty,
nasty kicks.
His actually,
his mom taught him about it.
Karate Pedis,
the both of the brothers,
brothers,
they have nasty taekwondo.
They started out and taekwondo and then
they learned from Duke Roufus all the
other fundamentals of kickboxing and
mma.
I think that's a good combination.
It's a good way to do it because
otherwise it's hard to learn those
kicks.
It's hard unless you're feet to her.
How the fuck that kind of like
downloaded a black belt to his brain.
That's what Joe Silva said.
Yeah.
Well that's like he's a freak of nature.
But I was like St Pierre,
his first fight,
if you watch it in like second Canada
ring,
he can't wrestle were shit.
Nothing,
now he's like,
no one can do that,
but wasn't a fascinating.
Now when you saw him lock up with Johnny
Hendricks,
he couldn't take Hendrix down.
Yeah,
I mean that's,
that's the difference between,
you know,
you catch a guy,
especially not in the transition,
not in between punches,
but actually just just trying to take
him down.
Good luck.
Henry's hopping around on one leg,
punched him in the face,
nothing.
And George couldn't take them down.
Which is crazy when you think about how
good George's wrestling is in a lot of
his other fights.
Not that was a johnny did a.
he's a burden.
I thought,
dude,
it was funny when the fight.
No,
he wanted to fight.
he won the fight.
He got robbed.
But I think almost everybody that I've
talked to that watch that fight,
he said,
I want to say a period of when they
don't really know what.
I didn't want him to fight Johnny
Hendricks,
in my opinion,
college tech beat Hendrix.
That was a bad decision.
I don't think.
I think Katrin won that fight.
I was ready for Hendrix because I didn't
like how strict.
I thought it was a very close fight.
That's for sure.
I thought that if I was seeing pure man,
I would say fuck
that.
I would fight Anderson and retire.
I think it could be the Anderson who's
actually can't wrestle.
He's had headaches for the last couple
of years,
George.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Freddie Roach was just talking about it.
George has had some migraines.
He's been talking to them about it over
the last two years has been suffering
from Migraines,
so that was the personal problems we was
talking about.
Well that was one of them.
I think there was some other stuff that
he doesn't want to talk about,
but the physical problems are legit.
When he was on the podcast,
man,
he was talking to me about aliens and he
was talking about like I was.
I was pushing him.
I was like,
you believe in aliens,
you believe?
Like apparently when they filmed the
countdown show with him primetime show,
there was a whole segment that they
filmed while he was talking about like
worrying,
like has nightmares about being abducted
by aliens and then he has it in his mind
what he would do if,
if aliens came.
And Anthony Junior,
Donald told me about this,
I go,
why didn't they put that in the show?
Like the UFC didn't want to have that
in.
And I was like that's crazy.
So I asked him about it on the podcast
and one of the things he was talking
about though was about missing time.
Sometime I'm in my car and then all of a
sudden I'm at the gym and I don't know
how it got there.
And like,
okay dude,
like that is not aliens
that's called we had too much and it's a
fact because I'm not that.
I don't think I punched drunk,
but I lose my car all the time.
Now.
Eric Jensen,
j rock fight.
Actually I lose my car,
look like if I go through them all,
my car's gone.
I literally do.
I have to fucking get a flag.
And put it on his roof.
I got to put A.
I put a little note in my phone like
level four,
like I had to put a note.
I'll lose my car if I park like memento
for parking.
I do,
but like a Broan is worse than me
though.
Even if you forgets things I can.
You asked me that same question like
five times in a day.
No,
but this is just,
I mean everyone who fights noses,
dangerous sport.
That's why I get pissed off when the
football players are suing the NFL
motherfucker.
You guys made millions.
It's a violent sport.
You knew you're going to get a head
injury like you got paid what you could
do.
You know what I mean?
And we,
we,
we don't get paid.
I don't think what we do and we're
getting the same injuries when nothing's
gonna happen to us.
We're going back to the wrestler.
The rest of the movie is gonna Happen to
80 percent of fighters.
You know what I mean?
I'm hoping that they're going to figure
out some sort of a medical solution.
I feel like if you look at the
advancements in science and medicine and
what they've been able to figure out
about how to fix all sorts of injuries
that fixing traumatic brain injuries
probably next,
and I know that the,
uh,
this uh,
thing called the intrepid center for
excellence and they work with soldiers
coming back from the war that have brain
injuries to big issue and they've made
some big improvements and helping
people.
Um,
but I,
I'm,
I'm with you.
Um,
I would way rather see a fighter retired
too soon and too late and it bums me out
when I see a guy that's been in too long
and I see them struggling
and you know,
the worst part is,
is if you,
they're doing it just because they need
money.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like,
like,
you know,
some guys like they didn't even retire,
but these don't,
they needed for their money when they
take
fights,
they shouldn't take short notice.
Whatever,
when they're not prepared against a
dangerous guy too.
And they get more damaged,
you know?
Exactly.
Well,
that's a real,
that's a real issue.
You know,
nobody wants to fight this guy,
well,
why do you think nobody wants to fight
this guy because they're not the same
level as him and because if they do
finally going to get knocked the fuck
out,
and then they say they're scared that
they're gonna get fired and that's not
like you can't say that a guy scared
because nobody,
everyone entering into the UFC is not a
perfect finished product.
They're just not.
It's,
it's a development cycle that goes
through the entirety of your career and
one of the things about boxing is they
know where their fighter is at and they
try to match them up well before they
give them a title shot.
If you look at boxing,
you'll see a lot of guys challenging for
the title that only have like maybe one
last two losses in their entire career
and a lot of them happen early because
they get a manager and they slowly build
them up and then they start testing them
and they do test them,
but they test them once they develop
some serious worldclass skills.
Boxing,
you fight nothing but chumps pretty much
like you.
You,
you,
you get a lot of work,
easy,
easy guys.
Step up a little bit.
So he did.
If he didn't do good,
pull them back the next time.
Make it easier,
you know what I mean?
They have so many fights.
I thought that's how the guys get like
30,
you know,
you know what I mean?
Because they didn't fight it.
No 1:30,
you know,
they realize also that that's the way to
make the money,
the way to make the money to build up a
manny Pacquiao to build up a ricky
Hatton to build up a floyd mayweather.
You gotta have a lot of fights like
floyd made.
They're made,
whether it's the only one has been able
to go through the fire over and over and
over again and come on undefeated.
See and there's a special athlete and
then the thing like,
I don't want to knock on the UFC because
that's your boss.
Whatever.
What you work for them,
but like you,
she doesn't want to.
Margaret Carter was one of the market,
the UFC.
Well,
it's smart.
If you were a business,
we're a business.
It's smart to market fighters as well.
Look,
Ronda Rousey,
I know how much Ronda Rousey's making.
She's making incredible money.
If you're a paper view draw,
if you're a George St Pierre,
if you're someone that's making a ton of
money,
you make you make money based on how
many paper views you sell,
so they're.
They're making shitloads of money,
so there's what people read online as
far as like how much the UFC pays.
It's like these are the disclosed
revenue.
They disclosed incomes,
but that's not what they get paid.
There's a bunch of other shit involved
as well.
There's there's bonuses and then on top
of the bonuses there's what they get for
each paper view sale,
so they don't disclose and a lot of is
because a lot of fighters don't want
people to disclose,
but if you're a guy who's start now and
you want to eventually work your way up
to to get to championship status,
like it's a fucking minefield.
Like look at Brock Lesnar is a perfect
example.
I was talking to Dana about this last
night.
Is there ever been a guy,
whereas fucking second fight and he's
fighting the former UFC heavyweight
champion is who mirror was in his prime.
I mean mayor was,
you know,
as good as he's ever been.
When brock fought him,
know that his problem was that he was
famous.
He had to be thrown in there and you
know what Kim was last,
I think at the same kind of problem.
Kimbo slice it when he sucks.
He's only been training a couple of
years,
dude,
but he doesn't suck.
You just inexperienced.
He has potential,
but he was too famous,
too fast and he had a fight to go to
guys too fast and got washed out.
You know what I mean?
It was like his own a marketing,
you know,
guerrilla marketing on the Internet
stuff worked for him and against them,
you know?
Did you ever see the Sean Gannon fight,
the old old,
old,
old way back in the day before.
That is one of the great.
Pull that shit up,
Shawn Garrett versus Kimbo slice.
That is one of the greatest displays of
heart ever.
For folks who don't know,
Kimbo slice became famous on the
Internet for all these crazy knockouts
in his backyard fights.
He'd fight dudes,
bare knuckle boxing,
backyard fights,
beat the shit out of them,
make all this money,
and he was just cool looking cat with
big,
big giant tub knuckles and really nice
guy.
Super Nice,
Super Nice Guy.
He look at his image,
you think one thing and you meet him.
He's so friendly,
ready to throw down.
He's just ready to throw it down.
So he became famous and there's a cop
from Boston named Sharon Gannon.
This motherfucker has a head,
like a fire hydrant and this is when
they were in the middle of it.
This is like the.
Everybody broke it up.
They got on.
There was a lot of money.
No wrestling.
Yeah.
He said it had to be a stand up fight.
Well,
he got him in a standing good team and
he's putting them to sleep and all these
people are jumping in and saying,
no wrestling,
no wrestling there.
Literally pry in the two of them apart
and Kimbo if you tuned it to begin,
Kimbo was tuning them up in the
beginning of the fight,
but that guillotine,
man,
if a guy's good and he gets you in a
good tune,
you're fucked because he's gonna.
He's gonna.
He held onto that good team for about 30
or 40,
so yeah.
Kimbos tired as fuck that.
Yeah.
No one's saying anything when Kimbo shot
for example,
but that was because Sean was battering
him by this point.
It was just cardio.
Couldn't hang with the Cardio Kimbo shot
on him,
which is crazy.
And then,
you know,
see him there.
Everybody's freaking out.
He couldn't hang with the cardio and you
also couldn't have ganas.
Just an animal.
That motherfucker could take punishment.
That,
that was a tough jump.
That was a tough fight.
I remember watching that back in the
day.
Well,
gannon started posting on the
underground from the hospital after this
fight.
Over the day,
man,
I watched this shit live on the
Internet.
It was like a paper view street.
He lost his job because he did something
happened.
He got demoted or he got in trouble
something,
but he was a cop.
That is the last motherfucker you want
to rest in you.
He's just so tough man.
Because Kimbo slice hit him with some
bombs.
His face was completely swollen and
bloody by the end of the fight.
But that dude had just no give up in
him.
And plus he had been used to MMA.
You know,
he had been used to fighting with better
plugs and not only that,
pacing himself,
like Kimbo Kimbo just fighting dudes
national.
He just jumped out of the gate.
I mean Kimbo obviously had some good
punching skills,
but as far as like his defense and as
far as like his,
his ability to pace himself,
like he was really way outclassed and
Gannon started tuning them up with body
shots and slowly but surely he starts
beating them down and by the end it's
absolutely brutal because they're giving
them these crazy counts to the game,
like a 30 count or some shit like that.
And they,
when the guy goes down,
you don't follow him.
Like in mma,
you got to let them get back up.
But I mean,
he could have died easily.
Kimma was absolutely exhausted and he's
getting just force fed knuckle
sandwiches.
But this was a,
this was a perfect indication that
although he became famous on the
Internet,
like he had a lot of growth to be
fighting guys in the UFC.
You know,
guys like Brandon Lee Hinkle,
like national class wrestlers.
You been not getting up off your
backside.
He got the guy gets you down.
You're,
yeah,
you're not getting up.
That's a terrible a type of match up.
And so Gannon went in there against
those guys too.
He,
he fought permanently hinkle in,
uh,
in the octagon.
And kimbo fought.
He fought quite a few guys who actually
did well.
He,
he,
he got better.
He got better.
We still do.
These guys have so many years on him.
He had some bad,
nice to hae a Kimbo.
Had some serious arthritis in his knees.
It goes crazy.
Band people never died on the wars.
Like I remember.
I remember I was backstage members.
Do you ever go to Draca?
Yeah,
I went to the Olympic Auditorium.
I was like in high school,
but I'll go there and like Kennedy with
fight,
I was at one one time and the guy from
France fought and like of that until he
died.
Whoa.
It was like,
what the fuck?
Nothing happened.
It was like a,
you know what I mean?
Like it wasn't like that where you
think,
oh,
someone dies.
You wouldn't be surprised.
Nothing happened.
You know?
It's always those kind of weird fights.
People just die.
There's die,
but the war is like,
they're fine,
you know?
Well,
they say that most of the people who die
cut weight really say that.
Yeah.
Most of the serious issues of brain
death and,
and real serious brain damage from a
fight happens and the weight classes
below heavyweight.
But there was a recent fight on hbo were
a guy wound up in the hospital with
swelling and the blend some Russian
dude.
It was a ferocious beating and it was a
heavyweight fight.
It was a heavyweight fight.
This Cuban Olympian and he,
he just beat the fucking shit out of
this Russian dude.
And the Russian dude was just
unbelievably tough.
Just kept coming.
And his face was swollen out to here by
the end of the fight and apparently he
had some serious brain swelling after
the fight in his career is done.
Yeah.
This shotgun.
And after that I was crazy.
Oh God.
That's nuts.
That face.
It's nuts.
And that's the winner,
dude.
That's our share.
Might look like after the first time.
Yeah.
I was there because I was.
I was feeding him ice cream in the hotel
room.
Yeah,
because I drove with them and he was
fucking
up man.
He got beat up.
He fought that fight with a torn acl
too,
right?
Yeah.
I mean fighting a guy like tito with a
torn acl.
And Tito was Tito back then to now the
tables on fire yet dude,
Tito had,
in my opinion,
still to this day has some of the best
ground and pound from inside a guard
because he didn't even bother passing
the guard.
You weren't going to control his
posture.
He wasn't going to let you.
And he was just dropping elbows on you,
smashing you from the top.
He battered can afford.
He had a lot of people could learn,
like there was a lot of people that
thought they had good guards and they
had fight Tito and you get stuck in
between,
you know,
he,
he was smashing guys from their guard.
The guard didn't mean shit to Tito.
He never even got close to getting
caught.
I remember getting caught ever.
He doesn't get enough credit.
That guy,
you know,
a lot of it's because of things he says,
a lot of it is a little fuck ups here
and there that he's done.
But like as a fighter,
you know,
just because he couldn't beat chuck.
Tito.
Tito was still a great fighter.
Tina.
He doesn't,
he doesn't get nearly enough credit.
Especially.
I think he has some of the best ground
and pound ever.
Everyone wants you to lose it.
Ain't no suck.
It sucks.
It's just easy.
It's easy to shit on them,
eh?
You know,
that's the thing that's like sports shit
to sports radio.
They love to shit on players.
The guy drops the ball,
he's a fucking bomb.
They love to do that,
but in the end it,
they apply it.
They try to apply that shit to fighting
and then you're dealing with a way more
personal subject.
You know,
the guy's a pussy.
He's scared of junior dos Santos.
Let's just say it will just come out and
say it.
Like,
why you talking like that?
Like what do you know?
What are you saying?
You know what?
How about you getting their stupid?
You wouldn't be scared for junior dos
Santos to punch in the face.
You'd have to be crazy to not be scared.
Dude.
I can't even.
I can't watch mma around civilians.
You know what I mean?
Like they're fucking,
they say the craziest shit.
You know what I mean?
Do you find it like drunk?
Especially drunk white guys try to talk
extra tough if they're watching MMA
around you.
Oh yeah.
Oh No.
And then drunk guys sober.
People don't do as much drunk.
They'll come with you right away.
But it's always in wanting to tell
stories of fights and fights.
There's been no.
I did not want to talk about fighting.
Not give a fuck about fighting.
I guess they feel like that's all you
can relate to.
It's like,
dude,
I fucking train all day.
I don't care about fighting.
I don't want to watch the fight.
I want to talk about fighting like this.
Talk about that girl's ass.
I have a friend,
I have a friend and her boyfriend
doesn't know anything about martial
arts.
He's never trained a day in his life and
he likes to watch fights,
but when he watched his fights,
he,
he starts like getting all aggressive
and saying crazy shit and she gets mad.
Know she's like,
this guy's a fucking pussy.
I kicked this fucking guys.
That's guys push and she's like,
will you shut the fuck up?
You ain't kicking.
Nobody's asked like,
why are you saying that?
You know how annoying that is?
It is the word I'll give you this
fucking guy.
He's going to.
So are you saying that it doesn't suck
man?
That's the perspective.
Get up the fuckers like you don't think
he wants to get up just laying there for
you.
He wants to get up.
You can't.
Fuck man.
Why isn't this knock him out?
He's trying to knock them out.
What did he advise you to knock him out?
It's so frustrating here.
And people critique fights when they
have no idea what they're talking about.
No,
he's ever hit them.
You know,
if there was enough and punched like
what,
what are you looking to punch you?
Knock.
Like someone was telling me about the
Chris Weidman.
Anderson Silva looked like a fixed fight
to me,
bro.
There was nothing punch.
He caught him perfectly on the end of
the chin.
Like,
has anybody ever hit you in the end of
your chin?
Let me tell you what happens.
Your legs just go.
We,
we,
they just give it a,
you know,
knock out.
So weird.
Like you remember when um,
lawler lawler,
India's.
Yes.
There were slugging it out and he
knocked him out.
It was a week.
I mean it was like a little tip.
Like it was a weird right hook.
Yeah,
it was like a softer one.
It looks like nothing but it knocked him
out.
I've been hit hardest elbow head.
The weights in the gym.
Fine.
And I've been dropped by a little guys
because if it hits you in the right
spot,
you're just done.
Yeah,
it's weird.
Sometimes were punched.
Doesn't look like it should knock out.
Like remember when Henzel gracie fought
Dan Henderson.
Hanzo is trying to shoot in on dance,
try to take him to the ground.
And Dan uppercut him.
He hits somebody.
It's like a upper cut,
almost like his wrist and,
and hence went out and like,
so could you versus a little knock.
Same Shit.
He hit him with a punch but he didn't
even land the punch.
He hit him with his wrist and he knocked
him out.
You know.
That's why I like people like I use the
term lucky punch.
I don't call it,
use it.
People say it was because you through
it.
Yeah.
Guess what though?
He through 65 hard ones that didn't do
shit and those software knocked them
out.
It's a lucky punch.
You know?
I've seen guys were like,
I'm beating up the whole fight as a last
minute left.
And you close your eyes and overhand
right.
Knocked me out.
So lucky punch.
Do you know what I mean?
Like the sex thing sort of,
but then again,
okay,
here's a perfect example.
Like Marcus Davis and Jeremy Stevens.
Marcus Davis was outbox and Jeremy
Stevens,
but Jeremy Stevens landed a few good
shots but not enough to put them away
and then finally in the third round hit
him with just his haymaker from Jupiter
and landed right on his chin and Marcus
was stretched.
He was out cold,
but I mean he hit him with all these
punches before it didn't do it,
but he was looking for that perfect
punch.
That's not a,
that's not a lucky,
but you know,
but sometimes there are a few.
Yeah.
And just like fuck,
like weird shit happens.
When Matt Hughes Fought Matt Serra,
they collided heads and Matt Hughes went
down.
He thought he got punched but it was
like a head.
But that dropped and he went to the
corner.
It's like,
what hit me?
Did I get,
did I get dropped?
And like they thought he got hit by a
punch,
but we watched it in the replay.
You could see they'd collide heads and
he,
he gets dropped from that.
Yeah.
You know,
there's a.
and that's why I think standup a little
more shaky because there's,
there's more luck than standup.
Yeah.
Then there isn't wrestling and Jujitsu.
There's also more.
What's important is like things that
you're physically born with,
like reach and athleticism and fast
twitch muscle fibers that come into play
way more with standup.
Whereas a guy can get real good once
you.
If you teach a guy the fundamentals of
striking and he's a long tall guy,
you know,
he could get real good,
real effective real quick as opposed to
a short,
fat white guy who's good short ass arms
and you're fucked man.
You the physical.
But that short guy,
if they were just rolling,
if that guy was a wicked black belt in
Jujitsu,
just knows positioning.
He could just run around that dude time
up in a knot and do whatever he wants to
them.
Yeah.
So you can get like a black belt in
striking.
You don't have to be as athletic.
Yeah,
I mean,
but that's the weird thing too,
like with me and Brian were talking
about it,
about like uh,
the end of the day,
everything's genetics.
Like we know right away the race horses,
bloodline,
the fighting dogs,
[inaudible] fighting,
roosters,
bloodline,
it's all blurred.
Those are the best animals were a
fucking animal.
So like it comes a lot.
Like some guys are freaks while they
fixed because genetically they're just,
they're magic,
you know what I mean?
So it's like Bj Penn.
Yeah,
he's,
I don't know,
George Foreman.
Yeah.
These guys are just fucking freaks.
So you know,
uh,
you can want to get so good dude.
It's like,
to me like Jeremy Horn is an example of
someone that's a great fighter really
tight.
The,
he went as far as you could go off skill
and an effort,
but he'd never had the athleticism.
You know what I mean?
Where if you put that skill into st
pierre or pg pan,
they would kill everyone.
You know what I mean?
Genetics is a lot.
That's why the perfect storm is a guy
like gsp.
You has the genetics and works like a
motherFucker and is smart and most guys
that had the genetics,
you're lazy like bj.
Yeah,
and I mean,
well it's interesting seeing bj come
back now because bj is going to fight at
1:45
and he's already down to like 1:55
and he's already in the fifties.
I've seen pictures on me skinnY as shit.
It's crazy.
It's just,
I don't know,
like those last few fights like the nick
diaz fight and the Roy Macdonald fight,
like what kind of a beating he took in
those fights.
FighTs were like first round effort and
then shut down and then it was like he
was trying to win,
but it was basically on survival mode
for rounds two and three.
There were two fights.
He should have never taken against one
seventies.
I mean the fact that he's now at 1:45
is just so crazy that he just is so
extreme goes from I'm not going to cut
weight,
I'm just going to fight anybody at one
70 and then I'm fighting at 1:45.
That's a giant difference.
Yeah.
But he's one guy that I think maybe
should be lighter,
other other guys cut weight and it's
like,
dude,
it's not.
The answer was like,
why don't you go to 50 fives?
Because I don't think I'm gonna do.
But if 55 to 87,
I'm fucking lean.
Fifty five.
Can I make it?
Yeah,
I could.
But am I going be better that?
I don't think so.
I think it's always the curious,
like really weak.
I was just talking to john,
alyssa,
we started yesterday and I said,
man,
you can stay at 55.
He waS like,
fuck,
I don't know man.
He said that at one 70 was always small.
Like alessio in shape is like one 75,
like perfectly in shape.
But he was like,
I'm smaller one the 50 fives.
He said 70.
No one ever muscled me around and $55 I
told them to get manhandled.
So it gives is weak.
It isn't always the cure.
Like everybody wants to go lower,
lower,
lower.
But I don't think it's.
Look at cane.
Yeah,
40 but a little fat on him and he be the
best headwinds for small look at federal
with small gains.
Small.
Randy was tiny.
Yup.
And they're fighting giants.
So like if I want,
if I find one 70 and the guys 10,
12 pounds heavier than me,
it ain't heavyweights lift 30 pounds
heavier,
they're fine.
Well the thing about those really big
heavyweights is they can't keep the
pace.
They just can't keep that kind of a
You saw with shane carwyn,
so brock lesnar see with allister they
can't keep that pace.
There's too much muscle to feed.
You can't keep that cain velasquez pain
because people,
people think our hearts and lungs are
kinda all the same size.
Your body might be bigger,
but you're the same size,
heart and lung.
We got to feed that muscle.
Yeah,
that's a weird thing that people don't
really understand.
They see a guy,
they go,
well,
you know,
he's just got to get In better shape.
You know,
he's got a fucking 500 horsepower
engine.
He's got three gallons of gas.
That's just what you got.
Your heart
and lungs are or uniform.
You don't.
Yeah,
because no matter how big words that
it's like,
it's like you're like a weaned dude.
Like john doesn't have a huge dick
guaranteed.
You know,
this is true.
It doesn't go.
It would be giant in comparison.
Most likely.
Maybe like shaquille o'neal.
Someone told me he had a little deck.
I told him to shut the fuck up.
First of all,
you've got to show me a picture.
You can't talk shit like that.
Second of all,
little dick.
Compared to what?
What is he like,
Jay?
So imagine if shaquille o'neal is so
humongous.
Like say you had eight inch dick,
big dick.
It's kinda like tanya,
I should feel like he has to have like a
15 inch dick to make it look normal.
It's true.
You know what I mean?
So,
but you know,
tHe lungs,
lungs,
hearts and dick's the big.
Well big guys have bigger lungs.
Don't think.
I mean you must,
you must have a larger heart too.
I don't think it's that much bigger.
I don't know.
Like I like shaquille o'neal.
I mean,
because think about your heart,
tony hinchcliffe say they say the size
of your fist,
right?
Right.
Well your fist came with that much
bigger.
Maybe it's a little bigger,
but 50,
60 pounds heavier.
Well that sucks for people with little
hands and they got little last hearts
because you know,
you know some dudes he likes to see
their face and you're like,
wow,
this is crazy.
That's always what I hear.
I don't know if it's true,
but it can't.
I think they're about the same size of
the heart.
Well either way there's not that much of
a variation and the amount of variation
in muscle mass that people put on,
it's pretty huge.
Like if I'm,
if I'm one 75 makoto,
is gonna be better than if I'm fucking
2:35,
I'll be able to like see guys that carry
muscle mass and then they use it though.
Like hector lombard.
He's a scary motherfucker with a lot of
mass.
There's a few guys that like break those
rules.
Even mountain has good cardio.
Not bad.
We saw so,
so [inaudible] been in the game so long
he can relax and that's a big part of of
fighting.
It's just being able to relax.
It's brain brains the most of your
cardio,
keeping your mind like for example,
my name is right.
He has the obstacle course record at
bud's.
He's.
He can do any snowshoe marathons.
He can do crazy.
All kinds of circuits beat everybody
right,
but I'm one of five minute round.
He's going To die like a funny.
Yeah.
I'm like,
dude,
we could wrestle.
he could run.
He could wrestle all day,
but as soon as he's punching involved,
five minutes tightens up.
He's bed.
Dude,
you can run a marathon yet you can't
fucking spot dead brain is everything
that nick diaz had the press style for
that getting guys exhausted because he
wouldn't let him breathe,
and that's what people say.
Nightmare.
When when someone's punching you,
even if there's a little punches,
you can't relax.
You need to relax so you're holding your
breath all the time.
He's hitting you cleansing.
Within 30 seconds of that,
you're fucking exhausted and all those
little 50 percent punches start adding
up to nick diaz is a is a nightmare.
Yeah.
Nick is one of the biggest nightmares
ever.
He's probably the last person I want to
fight,
like if I want to fight the same period.
Yes.
Same here all day.
Really?
Yeah.
Diaz.
Just for my style at least it's a
nightmare because he don't know.
Man.
I don't.
I don't go.
I don't have to go backwards to go
forward with him.
He goes forward too much.
He's too good at it.
He's a nightmare to me.
I don't
know.
He's.
He revolutionized in my opinion that
like that style striking.
You never saw that before.
Like guys are throwing like 50 percent
punches and just staying on you and just
hitting you with volume.
It's crazy like that.
That was the style that didn't exist
before.
It looks.
It looks like gum.
Yeah.
It looks weird but it kicks ass when you
saw like guys melt,
like,
like frank shamrock,
frank shamrock melted.
He just melted under that barrage and
he's talking shit and frank can't
breathe.
And he's punched him in the face,
what bitch,
what pitch?
Eat that bitch and he's knuckle sandwich
and I'm kicking his ass and then frank
can't believe that he's getting his ass
kicked and he's getting talked shit to
like this on tv and he realized I'm not
going to beat this fucking guy and he
can't breathe because he's not getting
any breath because nick's hitting them
with 30,
40 fucking punches a minute.
Just not that type.
He has a difficult style to deal with.
Yeah.
He's throwing 150 punches.
Hitting you with 31 thing with nick is
like,
like period them easier because nick's
weaknesses.
Wrestling.
Yeah.
As long as you can.
Especially it'd be fine.
I can wrestle him down,
you know?
Yeah.
Uh,
but on the feet man,
nightmare.
Nasty potty shots too.
I was going to say is that 30 of his
punches are going to be hard punches to
the body and he,
he throws those fishes,
hooks to the body and lulls you to
sleep.
But a few pitty pat and then boom,
uhm,
the hooks to the body,
the paul daily fights.
Another perfect example of that.
Oh yeah.
And he can.
That's the other thing about nick is
that he'd take a fucking serious punch.
Do you see him?
He'll be pitter pattering Whack it
cracked.
Go right back.
Because he was just right back there.
Just lets you know.
So what,
so what bitch.
So you hit me bitch,
you know,
and then you see them extending their
hands to like when he fought cause
content and he,
he literally bitch slapped him.
He just opened palm,
slapped him in the face.
I mean,
who does that?
Who talks so much shit.
I love nick diaz is one of my favorites
of all time.
One of my favorites.
It just uh,
it's interesting to see different styles
and how those styles play out and see if
people could find a solution.
You know,
george found a solution to that style
but never came close to finishing them.
Never,
never really put them in danger.
It was like a very safety first version
of that.
Yeah.
Know what I'm happy about is lawler.
Dude.
What a resurgence.
I'm happy him for him to come back.
It's awesome.
Like,
I don't know where like I thought I
haven't even,
I never thought I waS going to come back
with that.
He's smashing everyone to see if you can
find online robbie lawler versus melvin
manhoef.
That's my favorite robbie lawler fight.
That was in strikeforce.
I know.
It's a scary dude.
Oh,
first of all,
the dudes,
the blackest man on the Planet.
Okay.
He's black as coal.
He's built like a fucking superhero.
He throws the nastiest kicks and
punches.
Nasty.
He's the only guy to ever knocked Mark
Hunt out in the first round with one
Punch and he's a 100 and eiGhty five
Pounds,
which is fucking crazy.
They fought in mma.
Mark hunt shot in on him.
I mean,
that's the tells you how fucking scary.
Melvin manhoef is he just a spring,
just a steel spring.
Just coiled back.
Ready to fucking explode on you.
So anyway,
he's teeing off robbie lawler fucking up
his legs.
Got robbie's not checking any of these
kicks and he's sitting in with these
inside low kicks,
had got robbed.
His legs literally flying up in the air.
And then robbie uncorked haymaker losing
every minute of the fight up until the
moment he uncorked punch and melvin's
eyes just roll way back into his head.
And that's the end of it.
Yeah.
This is the fight right here.
This is one of my all time favorite
robbie lawler fights because he was
getting.
See how his legs are flying up in the
air.
And melvin manhoef is one of the best
kickboxer boom there.
It is.
One of the best kick boxers to come out
of one of the best gyms.
He was one of the guys from mike's gym,
whereas that's where alastaIr started
training recently when he rebuilt
himself.
Mike.
Mike is responsible for badr hari.
He's got coconut saki over there.
A lot of those high level high level
guys from holland,
lola,
go con socrates,
go contact your golden glory.
No,
I don't know either way.
Badass fighters over there,
but robbie lawler,
he always has that one punch power,
durable and tough.
And he doesn't give a fuck who literally
legitimate doesn't give a fuck.
Dana told me,
they called robbie lawler,
told him you got a title shot against
johny hendricks is for the welterweight
title.
He goes,
cool.
That's it,
you know,
do a,
he's a nice guy.
I like him,
but to me it's kind of like a bimbo,
like he's like,
he's like simple and so nice and like
he's like a bimbo,
like arrowhead,
you know,
it's funny.
I don't know,
that's what I always got off.
Um,
you know,
uh,
I've had conversations with them.
He's not stupid but he's just like,
like real,
like,
I don't know,
you just like quiet and like he's kinda
like kinda like a bimbo.
I never talked to him that much.
I know what you're saying,
but that's just perception.
So I know I talked to him for a long
time because he was on,
he was one of the coaches fault or
fighter when I was on there.
Oh,
real other team.
So he was like real nice and like he
just seemed like,
you know.
Yeah.
Who,
what team were you on?
I was on sarah,
sarah,
and he was on here,
but he's like,
because he would always tell me back,
tell me,
uh,
the lord isn't spar.
I'm like,
yeah,
riGht dude,
laura's probably only,
there's this boy,
he's a striker.
So I asked him on the shoulder.
He was like,
nah man,
why would.
I was like,
I know how to fight.
I just like,
what?
You serious dude?
So yeah man,
I wrestled when I run,
I lift weights,
but it was like I don't spot,
I know how to fight already.
Like wow,
that's part of said it was just funny.
I was like,
it just seemed like a,
just like a,
like a rock,
like just like,
you know,
like seeing her.
I was like,
but pretty,
you know,
he's a nice guy but he just tough
faster.
BuT you don't it as a spark.
What do you think about that?
Because is that maybe a way to do it?
Like you don't take any damage so you go
into a fight and you haven't been hit at
all,
you know how to hit people and you know
how to get hit.
You've been doing it for years.
If you just stop now,
how much timing would you lose if you
did like a lot of work and you just
concentrated on drills with a real good
striking coach?
I wouldn't do it because I know one way
from the judges
by jail when he came on a jail like the
first couple of weeks,
few weeks of sparring.
I like.
I'm like flinchy and like I'm like
flexing and he didn't get to do anything
in jail though,
right?
Yeah.
All in all I could do there with
shadowboxing,
like pushups and squats.
I couldn't really work out.
I know that's crazy.
I wouldn't do it like me.
I only once a week just just,
just tuesdays and like with a little bit
like I said,
and that's it,
you know,
put ice,
do three days a week,
three days a week,
but it's too much I think.
I don't think you need to do that much.
Yeah.
This is a point of diminishinG returnS,
esPecially with taking shots.
EverYone who gets hurt in practice,
you know what I mean?
so I would spend more time doing other
stuff that's less dangerous and um,
you know,
running and stuff like that because I
think in the beginning when you're new,
I think it's important to spar because
you can get comfortable once you get
comfortable is less important because
you're relaxed and you're not,
you're not nervous no more and stuff.
So much of it is also dependent upon
finding people that you could trust a
spar with.
Like there was a,
when I first moved to hollywood in
[inaudible] 94,
I was training at the jet center and a
bunch of real cool guys there and there
was a bunch of real cool guys to spar
with.
Was this one dude in particular?
I forget his name.
I think his name was ed,
I forget,
but he was an older dude,
me and that duty spar all the time
because I knew that he would never try
to tee off on me and he knew that I'd
never tried tee off on him.
Everything was like 50 percent always.
He never,
he was never,
you know,
some dudes will 50 percent you and then
hit you with some shit and be like,
come on man,
what are we doing here?
Are we fight and we spark and the next
thing that you try to get them back.
next thing you know,
you're in a wall in berlin and you know,
in your brain up,
you know,
I don't believe that you need a spar
hard.
I don't think so either.
What I was going to say is this,
I got better with this guy.
my sparring got sharper,
my reflexes has got sharper because I
was constantly sparring with this dude
where I wasn't worried about getting
knocked out in,
in our training sessions.
You know,
it's uh,
you know,
either you're tough,
you're not dude,
so you didn't get hit and you're gonna
be a poster,
you're going to get hit and you're going
to take it.
And by that standard and you think
robbie lawler has got a point.
Do you think maybe his style of,
of not sparring it all,
it'll be a good idea for him,
for him?
Yeah.
Well that's it,
right?
Find what works for you,
you know,
like some guys,
I think you could get away with it more
than others,
but uh,
I wouldn't feel comfortable confident
doing it.
I've never heard the one I was doing
that except for him.
Yeah,
I wonder.
I mean,
who knows,
he might just be bullshitting.
He might like to spread rumors,
but he,
he was living with me for a little bit
in vegas like million back in the day.
so bernie,
that didn't spark and I was like,
fucking bullshit dude.
He asked us was probably only wants to
do a spoiler,
but.
So he needed confirmed it.
So I don't know,
dude,
I got to ask him,
but that's really interesting man.
That's really interesting.
But uh,
he's a scary fucking finisher though.
The check and he fought koscheck.
I mean,
the way he fights,
he doesn't,
he doesn't need this part obviously.
And maybe that'll save his brand in the
long run.
That's what I'm saying.
You get hit.
That's the problem with boxers is that
they only punch.
So they're getting hit in the head all
the time and practice and the fight.
So they get more brain damage than us,
you know,
I was probably once a week and I through
come dipping a hard.
When you see guys like,
um,
like meldrick taylor,
does that freak you out?
It's scary dude.
It freaked me out man.
I stopped sparring when I was in my
twenties.
I haven't done any sparring.
I'm 46 years old now and I still wonder
if what I did when I was younger,
like maybe it would have been smarter,
maybe I wouldn't have been so weird.
Like,
you know,
it can't be good at hitting the head.
Can't be,
you know what I mean?
That's why you got to accept the fact
you got to be careful with yourself and
you got to be smart.
Like for example,
um,
last week I was sparring with evan
dunham and I shot at the exact same time
he kicked.
It was like a fluke accident.
Super common though.
Yeah.
And boom,
dude,
I was on my,
I'm gonna ask like I was like pretty
much almost out,
you know.
And he's like,
sorry,
bad timing.
Oh,
what was this?
When did this happen last week?
Now what do you do when,
when something like that happens,
how much time do you take off as barn?
Depending on how I feel afterwards,
but like I took the whole week out,
but I was the only tuesdays anyway.
But um,
if I would've been dizzy like that night
still afterwards and the next day I
wouldn't have spotted for a couple of
weeks Because that's how you lose your
chin.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
But then it sucked because then like I,
like I said I was fine.
It was that that night I was already
fine.
It was a big deal.
But um,
then on tuesday we got this fucking
silver medalist olympic,
a guy from Denmark,
from martin cameron's buddy,
he's a silver medalist and he's,
he's,
he's officer no quicker,
ruined wrestler.
So it was probably with this guy
yesterday and he stand up,
isn't that good yet?
So I'm going to software and I don't
want to be a dick,
you know,
but then he took me down double leg and
I was good up on the fence and that
motherfucker suplex me on my head,
dude.
And uh,
I got,
I got rocked pretty good but not,
you know,
it was like a,
I was like,
that's what people don't realize this,
this shit is happening all day,
but you got to be able to judge like
saved at that.
SaY if a evan dunham that happened in my
last round last tuesday,
if that was my first round,
I would always stop for today.
If you get,
if you get dropped or knocked out a
rock,
don't or don't be tough.
Fucking take the day off because you're
gonna do more damage.
Your brain has to recover a little bit,
you know.
Not only that,
I mean you really need more than a day.
You probably need a long time.
A while.
I'm just kind of fucking crazy and at
least a week.
But I've seen like some guys will get
dropped and they'll take like a man
often despised the next round.
Done for the day.
Blacks.
It ain't gonna benefit you,
you,
I've seen guys get knocked out cold in
boxing gym.
They spar him later and he's like you to
do it now?
Fuck you.
Get Back on the horse.
Don't be scared to get back on the horse
and you see him spar and they're like,
yeah,
and then they get jazzed to get going on
and get jobs in Iraq.
Well that there's been a couple
instances in the ufc where guys get
knocked out in training camp and they
completed their camp and fought travis
luder when he knocked out,
um,
a marvin eastman.
Remember that fight?
Marvin eastman got knocked out twice in
camp.
He was trained with tito
and he got knocked out by a knee during
the takedown and another time that was
something else,
like during a take down,
he got knocked out.
So you've been concussed out.
Cold twice in camp and then fought.
And travis luder caught him with the end
of this punch.
It was kind of crazy.
It was one of the weirdest knock on
saturday.
Yeah.
It caught him like pull.
Pull that up.
Travis luder versus martin king never
knocked the other one in his life.
And he's a digital guy.
Travis luder versus marvin eastman and
these east.
Well,
you know,
louis luder could punch.
He's a strong dude.
I mean.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
he's a guy and these ones that striker.
So you thought he was gonna take him
down to try.
You know,
he's one of,
in my opinion,
look,
the guys that like didn't reach his
potential.
That makes me go.
He's fucking lazy.
Lazy,
lazy,
like wouldn't leave his gym like trained
with the students and shit like that.
He was smashing anderson silva.
Yeah.
And he gassed.
Here's travis right here.
I mean,
that's crazy.
We'll show that one more time Because it
doesn't even make sense,
but it's not like people.
You might think it was fake.
Watch this.
He hits him with this punch.
Here it is.
That's crazy.
It barely hits.
It's like a grazed.
Him at the very end of the punch.
And marvin eastman had just been
so damaged and training.
He just went out cold.
But travis luder was a wicked jujitsu
guy,
dominated everybody in the house.
When you see,
when he was fighting on the ultimate
fighter dude,
his fucking takedowns,
his jujitsu is laser sharp and he fucked
up and he fought anderson silva.
He lost so much weight.
Dude.
I never seen a guys I lost so closer to
death than the weigh ins for travis
luder.
He never made the weight.
He never made the way to miss the way
was a non title fight when he fought
anderson and when he got on that scale,
man,
his lips were cracked and bleeding he's
faced was completely sucked in.
There was no water in his body and he
was shuffled and I'll never forget that
he couldn't even walk.
He was shuffling towards a scale for a
second time.
This was after he missed weight on the,
on the stage.
They weighed him backstage afterwards.
He couldn't make the weight.
He was off by like a couple pounds to
it,
so it was a mess.
There was no way he was going to lose
any more weight.
He was going to die and so they changed
it to a non title fight,
but when if that guy had just earlier in
his career,
had moved to a bigger camp and gone like
the jacksons or american top team or
something like that and really gotten
shape,
he would have been a motherfucker shit
who was so strong.
Obviously diet and cardio,
you need a better training guys.
And it's cardio.
Yeah,
it was like guy medgar was the best ever
first round fighter in the world.
Guy was anyone the first finger dead,
but after that it's a wrap.
He would get tired,
you know?
Yeah.
Well gosh guy metzger,
he's,
he's another guy that had a real
problem.
He was taking vioxx.
He was taking some shit for his knees
and it was like an arthritis shit.
The turnout,
it would give people strokes.
She had a fucking stroke from this
medication.
Did he?
Yeah,
dude.
Yeah.
He never fought again.
But he,
like his friends started noticing.
He was like slurring his words like
crazy and you know,
it was like out of nowhere.
And so they,
they urged them to go to a doctor and
you went to a doctor and found out that
he had a stroke.
I'm pretty sure it was via.
I'm going to pull this up because I
don't want to speak at usc,
but I remember they pulled that shit.
A guy medsker one of the.
When they make it illegal,
but all these drugs.
Fuck everybody.
Oh yeah,
no kidding man.
Yeah,
man.
He did?
Yeah.
Okay.
that was,
it was vioxx.
Yeah.
And he,
he got a fucking stroke he took to uh,
they took him to the hospital.
funky.
Crazy.
Yeah.
I ain't know that.
Yeah,
you gotta be careful.
All of those medications that they can
give you for things like arthritis and
extreme anti inflammatory medications
like that,
they can have extreme effect on your
blood,
especially these like pharmaceutical
ones.
They pulled that shIt off the market.
I try to stay away from most all
medication.
You eat really healthy man.
I watched your,
your twitter feed for what you eat.
You eat almost totally vegan.
Right?
Well,
ever since I got out of jail I started
eating.
Um,
I never,
not like 90 percent vegan.
This what happens.
I read the China study and I already had
a friend that was vegan and I started
reading a lot and it just made sense to
me and I,
I believe this,
the study,
like a lot of stats and stuff and that
documentary forks over knives and stuff.
So I gave it a shot.
I'll try it out,
you know,
and,
and I mean I'm still a strong,
muscular whatever.
What are you getting your protein from?
You say 90 percent vegan.
So it's 10 percent animal protein.
Yeah,
basically what I do.
So my protein and there's a lot of from
I get a supplement,
a lot of powder from.
I like sponsored garden of life.
That's a great company.
Yeah,
well I got good stuff.
I liked their in jail and I was taking
that stuff and I was like fuck,
it was expensive.
I thought there are two main stream to
sponsor me.
you're like I'm a maniac,
you know,
x,
y,
zed,
that's why I want.
so I'm gonna email them and I was like
hey,
you know,
and they're like sure.
And I was like,
really?
I'll say just let you know like a jail.
I did porn and be like,
oh yeah,
we already googled you.
And I was like all right,
cool.
That's awesome.
But they're a great company.
But anyway,
I'm in the daytime mostly I make
smoothies just old like bananas,
spinach,
strawberries and the protein.
So do you avoid a big meal until like
later?
Are you doing that right now?
I'm doing this.
I'll try and his warrior,
the warrior diet.
I never read the book but I know the,
the,
I know a little bit about it but I like
it because here's what happens is that
my whole life,
you know,
uh,
I did the regular body building diet,
eat every two or three hours and it was
always easy in the daytime and
nighttime,
I'm starving and I want to cheat.
It was always the problem,
you know,
at nighttime was like,
fuck man,
I want to eat this or that and you
can't,
you can't cheat.
Right.
So then I read the warrior diet,
the theory behind it and I said,
well it makes sense man.
Like all day long,
I'm not hungry anyway.
So I did a little bit during the day and
then I'll pig out at night.
I have big,
big dinner.
So the last,
just just the last few months I've been
doing this warrior diet thing,
but basically all I do is only eat this.
I'll make a smoothie an hour before
practice.
And then I one right after practice.
One hour,
huh?
Yeah.
That's all you need is an hour.
I feel like it's good for me.
That's probably because it's a vegetable
base smoothie,
right?
Yeah.
It's all fruit and I've tried to do that
with like whey protein.
You start shitting your pants.
I wear it
brains out,
you know,
like way it comes from milk and it
tastes better than whey protein taste
better and stuff.
But I don't know,
I think,
I think it's bad from what I've read,
I try to stay away from all dairy animal
stuff,
especially dairy.
But then like what I usually do is like,
I'll eat vegan all week and sunday.
You're like a fucking pig.
I don't care.
You give a one cheat day,
like pizza,
like anything.
I don't care anything like nothing,
nothing forbidding but sometimes say
like a flight to go to sushi,
I'll get sushi tonight.
Big deal.
But in my house I only eat vegan.
That's interesting.
So most of my protein comes from mostly
beans,
rice,
a stash fields.
Um,
and then,
uh,
the protein.
But mostly I eat a boring diet.
Did the same thing every day.
Same time today.
That's smart because it freedom makes
me.
If I don't have a schedule,
I'm fucked.
I can't even if I have any freedom in my
schedule,
I'll screw it all up.
So I had that written down.
Eat this now.
Otherwise I'm screwed.
Like same thing.
Like if I even get woke up early,
I like,
my schedule is so exact.
Like today,
like I'm here,
right?
Uh,
if this ended early,
I wouldn't trade after this.
My skin is ruined already.
And on the way here I had the,
I already ate junk food.
I fucking went the jak inhibitor.
so you sort of manage yourself against
your own impulses?
Yeah,
because I know that like,
I had this,
but I don't.
If I have a schedule in front of me,
I'll follow it to a t.
If I don't have one,
I'm,
I can't trust myself.
You're too impulsive.
Yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
I can do it.
But at least you understand that,
you know,
if that's a trial and error thing,
and I think that's probably,
you know,
if you think about like your life and
all the circumstances that you've had in
your life,
those develop like paths they developed,
like behavior paths and those behavior
paths.
When you,
once you already go down that impulsive
road,
it becomes very difficult to break those
paths.
That's why people are like gambling
junkies.
They'll fucking fall off the wagon.
Just fucking let me just play one hand,
one hand a black chair and next thing
you know,
they're fucking sweating their collars
oN dawn.
Their fucking hair is crazy.
I,
I've,
I forbiD myself with a gamble.
Yeah.
I'm not a gambler either.
Uh,
yeah.
But this right now my diet,
I like to do,
don't.
I don't think we need to eat them that
much.
Animals and stuff.
You know,
the child studies shows like in the ras
and stuff that if the rats that ate a
more than 10 percent animal products,
the cancer that would turn on and then
they'd take them to a 90 percent of
their diet and they would turn off the
cancers.
Well,
I'm here to tell you that I'm an
american and I'm not a fucking rat.
I'm a human being top of the food chain.
I'll eat a rat if I'm hungry,
but I don't like to base my died of some
shitty road and said eat themselves.
Yeah.
Well,
here's the thing too,
when you think about it.
All right,
so we're in tribes.
Okay.
So those guys are the hunters.
We're going to go out all day and hunt
along the way when we're going to be
eating fucking apples and wherever we
find.
Right.
Whatever we could find.
We gonna getting along the way.
The chicks are going to be at home,
you know,
hunting or gathering and a clean shit up
and w we,
we get a pig,
we bring it home at nighttime and we
have a feast,
but it's one pig we caught maybe and
there's a whole fucking village so we're
all gonna get a small amount of meat and
mostly we're going to eat vegetables and
plants and stuff,
but just to let you know,
I mean I don't know how much you've done
online.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with eating a vegan diet and I'm a big
proponent in eating a lot of vegetables.
I eat a lot of vegetables.
I think I feel better when I drink kale
shakes and eat a lot of fresh
vegetables,
but the China study has been debunked by
many different scientists.
There's been a lot.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It has.
There's been a lot of different work.
One of the things they accused the China
study,
I was cherry picking data in order to
match their conclusions that they wanted
to make.
Like there's this,
if you just google China study debunked.
There's a bunch of different articles
about it like here,
here's one rest in peace China study,
and it's all about a guy who wrote a
story.
I started analyzing the,
the original,
trying to study data.
He said,
I had no intention of writing and actual
critique of a campbell's much lauded
work.
I'm a data junkie numbers along with
strawberries and audrey hepburn films,
blah,
blah.
But after spending a solid month and a
half reading,
gRaphing,
sticky noting and passing out at 3:00
AM from studious exhaustion upon my copy
of the raw China study data,
I've decided that it's tiMe to voice all
my criticisms and there are many and
this guy just goes into all these
different points where there's like the.
He said,
campbell was influenced by his own
expectations about animal protein and
disease,
leading him to seek out specific
correlations in the China study data and
elsewhere to confirm his prediction,
which means that he didn't use real
science.
What he did was he used confirmation
bias and he tried to go towards a lot of
vegans do that,
man.
Like,
I tried,
I had this.
Uh,
what's the,
the endurance runner that we had on
the dude talking about?
Anyway,
cat was a vegan,
really good guy.
And we were,
we were talking about,
uh,
about v rick roll.
We were talking about ritual,
we're talking about veganism and you
know,
and he was saying that it had nothing to
do with not wanting to eat animals.
It just all about health.
So I started talking to him about the
benefits of fish oil and you know,
and he was like agreeing that there's a
lot of health benefits officials.
I do supplement with fish oil.
Well,
he's like,
no,
no I don't.
I'm like,
well why wouldn't you,
if you know all the benefits official
because it becomes a thing where you
want to say you don't eat any animals.
Here's the thing,
like my old buddies or my old roommate
was a vegan real deacon,
like reading labels and shit.
I will never do that.
And I don't believe in the whole hundred
percent vegan diet.
I believe that.
I think I,
my opinion is we're meant to eat some
meat but mostly plants.
That's what I think we are probably
meant to eat naturally,
but uh,
like I'll eat whatever I want to grow a
great deal of benefit to eating animal
protein.
Now a lot,
especially
animal protein that's grass fed.
You start looking into a wild game and
grass Fed animal protein and the
difference between like the essential
fats,
there's like way more,
uh,
that was like the salmon essential fatty
acids are way more than the wild game,
much more,
much more.
Well,
you know,
the problem is most people,
when you're judging diets,
here's one gigantic thumb.
The sore thumb that sticks out.
Most people have sedentary lifestyles.
So if you start judging the diet of the
average american,
what the fuck is the average american
doing with their on their shit?
Yeah.
So you can't even compare the average
american to an athlete.
But when you start talking to athletes,
talk,
talking about the specific nutritional
demands of your red line and your
fucking body every day when you're
training,
when you're doing strength and
conditioning.
I've seen the videos you were,
you're doing chin ups would fucking
weight belts on and 90 pound dumbbells
on in between your legs,
your red line and your body all the
time,
but you need as much protein,
nutrients,
essential fatty acids,
vitamins you need all the good shit.
You can't afford to have a deficiency in
any area you should look into if you're
not opposed to it from a moral
standpoint.
Look into the benefits of grass fed
proteins.
That's why I like the way I'm doing.
I do both,
but mostly the plants.
I think as long as I'm.
My energy's high and my muscles staying
the same strength,
the saying like I could judge you by
that kind of.
I feel I feel good.
You know what I mean?
It's definitely better than the average
diet.
Yeah,
and the thing is too,
this is why in jail I stopped reading
fucking fiction fiction is the real
shit,
right?
Books.
Fiction is fake over the nonfiction.
So now he's.
The reason why in jail I stopped reading
nonfiction was because oh fucking read
one book written by four phds and
they're telling me this right and not
read another book by four phds and they
told me the opposite.
No one knows shit and it pisses me off.
So the after awhile I started reading
only fixing just stories.
I don't give a shit,
you know,
because I got sick and tired of reading
them,
contradict each other and no one knows
nothing.
We'll see what's going on is that
there's not enough.
It's not that no one knows anything.
It's just like people are still learning
and they're still learning about the
body.
I mean if you just look at training
methods that people used to use just 100
years ago in comparison to training
methods today,
you ever watched like those old training
camps like Jack Johnson and jack and
jack dempsey and all these guys just
doing all this crazy like old school
training methods.
It's silly.
Their bodies look different like
athletes or just different.
Today we understand tabata methods,
we understand different protocols for
endurance training.
You understand heart rate monitors.
We understand overtraining,
who understand like hydration,
electrolytes.
There's just so much they understand
today.
They did.
They didn't know.
Then.
It's constantly growing.
It's not.
I think the main problem is though is
like if me and you are a scientist and
we figured out this thing like we think
that we're right,
but then we like the design since they
fucking.
They refuse to believe they're wrong and
they,
they'll push this even though now they
know it might be wrong with them.
They don't.
They wasted so much time to fucking make
this right.
Now they're scared it.
Same thing with the flat earth and
around with all that bullshit.
Same type of theory.
You know what I mean?
We're like,
you know,
they get committed to their idea.
They didn't want to budge.
they would rather preach their idea even
though it's not right.
Then let go,
and then that's the problem too with the
sign shit.
Well,
that's an issue with people that study
ancient civilizations.
There's a guy that we've had on this
podcast several times,
so a good friend of mine named graham
hancock,
gregg guy who wrote this amazing book
called fingerprints of the gods and it's
all about ancient structures and they.
THey've taken geologists,
man,
they had this guy,
robert schoch from boston university.
They studied the erosion marks on the
sphinx and they're trying to backdate
the.
The enclosure for the sphinx and trying
to say rain,
right?
Yeah.
They say it's from thousands of years of
rain.
Problem was the last time they had that
kind of rainfall in the river.
It's like 9,000
bc,
so like we're talking about thousands of
years before that because back then they
used to be a rain forest denial.
We used to be like,
it's rich reinforce.
So what he's saying is that just based
on geological evidence,
you're dealing with something that was
constructed a long time ago,
much longer than anybody thinks,
but these egyptologists did not want to
believe they were digging their heels in
the sand and they were saying there's no
way.
It's impossible.
Whereas this,
they were laughing like,
oh,
here's this culture from 12,000
plus years ago you talk about,
and they didn't even know that anybody
had built anything like that from 12,000
years ago until recently they found this
structure in Turkey called gold beckley
tappy without a doubt.
12,000
plus years old because someone 12,000
years ago covered It because they've
proven by doing carbon testing on the
soil that it was all put at the same
time.
So they know the 12,000
years ago for sure someone was making
big crazy chinese shit,
but they don't want to talk about that
because they've been teaching college
courses in university and forever and
they gave a timeline because this
timeline has been established and that's
how they base their phds at today based
on their studies and their words don't
want to let it go.
And that's the problem.
You know,
there's a problem,
you know?
Uh,
uh,
I don't know.
It's a problem with ancient
civilizations for sure,
but it's a little bit of a problem with
health and a lot of these fucking people
that are talking about,
oh,
you don't need vitamins,
you don't need this.
Let me,
when we find out what you do with your
body,
because I have a feeling you're a fat
fuck,
can you just sit around doing nothing
mean telling people they don't need
vitamins,
they don't need nutrients.
I just thought I should.
That day on dr oz.
Dr was trying to tell them that you
don't need to take vitamins.
Bullshit.
And then dr.
Oz was saying,
well you need to take your daily
recommended allowance.
Fucked the daily recommended allowance.
Guys don't know shit.
I don't.
I don't believe none of that I take.
I take.
You know what I mean?
I don't,
I don't think it's going to hurt you to
mega doses of vitamins,
you know?
Well,
it's also they love to make these these
headlines like,
I don't know if you saw this recent
story that where this research is st
case closed vitamins don't work,
but they based it on two things.
I've talked about this before,
folks who listened and they like,
you got to fucking talk about it again.
One more time is the last time I
promise.
Just for war machine,
they based it on six people over 65 that
had had heart attacks,
that vitamins didn't keep them alive any
longer and people that were over 65 that
had already had mental decline.
They were already experiencing
alzheimer's.
It didn't slow their mental declines.
The likable,
but that's not.
Vitamin doesn't work.
you're dealing with old people that are
already there already.
A dead almost.
Yeah,
exactly.
Your heart attacks,
your brain stopped working and you
having a heart attack.
Oh,
fucking centrum one didn't work.
It didn't fix that.
That's crazy.
Unbelievable.
But this is a.
This is a headline to get press,
so they put these headlines out to get
their study,
to get people to read it and pay
attention to it.
It gets hits all these websites,
everybody gets excited about it,
they inflame the results because the
more you inflaming more people are going
to share them on twitter and the next
thing you know,
people were arguing that you don't need
vitamins.
There's just a study that released why
even taking vitamins?
These had study and there's no fucking
studies that tell you don't need
vitamins.
This the stupidity.
Yeah,
it was the same thing.
What's up with the soy milk?
I hear people say that it raises
estrogen,
but people say it doesn't.
Is there a real study?
Is soy?
Most definitely can have effects on your
hormone levels for men or just women or
men or men in the study?
Cause I hear both and I don't.
I don't know which one.
I'm pretty sure soy can affect your
hormone.
Well,
let's.
Let's just google it right now.
Can affect hormone levels,
hormone levels.
There's a lot of shit.
They're gonna affect hormone levels.
You got to be careful about having added
nami.
Nami,
he cries like a girl.
He grows milk when he eats soybeans.
That our drinking water though is so
full of a birth control pills when they
like,
when they cleaned it out,
the hormone staying in it's lauren
testosterone to.
Well,
there is some.
There's also antidepressants that make
their way into our tricky water from
people processing.
Like when people flush them down the
toilet was like when you drink water,
like in some places you're drinking
water that's been processed,
they'll process sewage water back into
the drinking and then somehow or another
micro doses of these antidepressants and
antibiotics and all kinds of shit can
make it into that water,
but the levels are so low address,
it'd be almost impossible to.
It's impossible to feel.
I think it's just.
It's just detectable.
Does soy.
Does eating soy increase estrogen?
Estrogen production?
Let's find out.
Yes it does.
Soy beans are a complete protein source
and a dietary staple of many cultures.
Store can.
Soy contains phytoestrogen is called
isol.
Flay isoflavones owns that may mimic the
activity of hormone estrogen in your
body.
The effects of soy isoflavones on human
estrogen levels are complex,
so it's safe for everyone to consume in
moderation and can have a modest effect
on estrogen levels,
so that means it can have an effect,
so don't get crazy and drink a lot of
soy mIlk or dick would go soft,
grow some titties,
or if you're a girl,
you need some extra estrogen.
Men.
Imagine if girls can eat like certain
foods and their tips.
We grow bigger.
There be none of that shit at whole
foods.
Try finding soybeans and hopefully it
will be out.
Yeah,
soy.
So it's always an interesting one,
but it's not the best protein.
Like keen was one of the best.
Yeah,
that's real high in protein and all.
All of a sudden amino acids.
Hampshire real good.
One to mcz digest to.
Yeah,
the one that I think that the garden of
life one and it's like a blend I think.
Yeah,
but you can get a lot of protein.
Maybe mac danzig pulls it off.
You can do a lot of protein in a vegan
diet.
You just gotta know what the fuck you're
doing.
The real issue is healthy fats too.
You got to eat avocados and shit.
You got to get a lot of fats or just
like a flax oil shake because I'm the
boss.
I'm not against.
I would take the fish oils.
I don't bother me.
Like mac wouldn't know.
He's a real,
real hardcore vegan.
Yeah,
he's an anImal.
He told me like,
fuck that.
That's bullshit.
Like you don't like.
And I,
I figured that he's been a deacon salon.
maybe he knows.
So I believed them.
He,
what did he say?
It was bullshit.
The soy shit.
Like that's bullshit.
There's no study that getting emotional.
That's the woman in them.
And the estrogen is making them
emotional.
Tell him to back off the beans back.
Yeah.
Well mac is,
uh,
he's,
he's an interesting dude because his,
uh,
he's got a real strong character.
I really liked that guy.
He's a very smart dude and he's a strong
believer.
Excuse me,
in character.
That's why he chooses not to have a,
of any animal protein.
He started for some reason I started
was,
was from like a sinus infections.
Strep throat.
Really?
Dairy man,
a lot of people have issues,
ice strep throat and sinus infections
like three times a year,
every fucking year since,
after,
since forever.
Right.
And then,
um,
I heard a rumor that if you stop
drinking milk,
it can go away.
I was like,
bullshit.
I tried it and it stopped.
Fucking I don't get it anymore.
Yeah.
Friend tony hinchcliffe for the same
issue.
Right.
He stopped drinking milk,
need cleared up a lot and my dad told me
this.
That's why he started to.
And then he,
after that he started researching more
and that's why he became a vegan and
plus the animal stuff.
But yeah,
you're not supposed to drink milk that's
been homogenized and pasteurized.
And the problem with drinking raw milk
is,
unless you know who's milking that cow,
that cow,
you don't know what the fuck you're
getting,
how they're dealing and handling the
milk right afterwards.
If you can get a good source though,
if you get a real good farm that's
reputable,
that knows how to deal with their,
their,
um,
the raw milk some.
There was a recent study also,
they try to discredit wall milk saying
one out of six people who drink raw milk
and get sick,
but then in the article itself it shows
that you can't prove that what happened
to them came from the raw milk and it
could have been from the only had raw
milk.
They weren't controlling the rest of
their.
Their input and their input varied.
Everybody's input varied and people get
sick all the time.
So it's real sketchy.
It's not like a double blind placebo
test taken raw milk because of rose to
homogenized or pasteurized milk and then
they both eat the same diet and it's
controlled st portions.
Living lab.
Yeah.
You,
you have to live in the same info.
You know,
it's,
it's hard,
but you've got to be careful.
You got to be careful whenever
anything's wrong.
You know you've got gotta have really
fresh stuff,
but that's what we're supposed to eat.
We're not speed,
speed,
old rotten.
So those refrigerators and all,
you know what I mean,
like.
Yeah,
but you know,
for,
for most people they're not going to be
able to afford to just buy milk every
day.
I mean that's really what we're not
supposed to live in societies where
you've keep up a steak for a month,
you know,
it takes not supposed to sit in your
refrigerator and the only way meet can
sit in your refrigerator.
It has to be like some fucking bologna
thing that's barely a meat,
you know?
It's just been filled with all kinds of
shit to the point where it can't.
Right.
She's hot dogs,
cheese,
hot dogs.
That's the worst.
What are those like meet with fake
cheese in it.
Oh god,
yeah.
That's terrible for you.
All that stuff just makes you feel
awful.
Just makes you,
your,
your body just goes into shutdown mode.
Even on my cheat day,
like I do,
just because a,
I'm a pig,
I want to have my pig day.
I always feel like shit.
Do you eat gluten?
Yeah.
See,
I don't know nothing about gluten.
I'd never really read up on it.
So like the real science behind my
cousin is a lawyer in Washington.
She has a bag gluten allergy where
she'll like be in bedridden for gluten.
She was telling me blah,
blah,
blah.
I mean,
I don't really know nothing about
gluten.
I have no gluten allergy.
I've eaten pasta all my life.
I'm italian.
I grew up eating bread and pasta,
but when I cut it out,
I noticed a big difference.
My face got skinnier,
first of all,
I felt like less,
less soreness in the areas that I
usually get inflammation.
Like my back.
I went to it because of,
um,
a therapist told me that she told me
they have good results with helping
people out back injuries by getting off
of gluten,
getting off gluten and sugar.
She's like,
anything bad for sure.
Terrible for you.
She's like,
these things,
they're not just bad for you.
She's like,
they're inflammatory.
And she goes,
and that's what the issue is.
The issue is inflammation.
And if you have foods that cause
inflammation,
it makes injuries more difficult to
heal.
Yeah,
iT was.
I was reading about all that shit,
like sugar and stuff.
It taxes your kidneys and your liver and
that they can't do their jobs right?
So your body has more toxins and this
should have and it makes your body
inflamed and blah,
blah,
blah.
Sugar's not good for it.
Too bad.
It's fucking delicious though.
God dammit.
Everything good for you is fucking
boring and bland.
everything delicious.
It's fucking terrible for you.
It's true.
That's where we are,
where we are as a person.
We haven't to figure out how to make.
They've got a genetically engineered
food to just be unbelievably delicious
but nutritious it.
What's that gmo?
That's the devil.
It's the devil or what?
Well,
here's what's up with gmos.
Some of it is good and some of it is
bad.
Just like everYthing else.
I mean,
there's things like golden rice,
they figured,
figured out a way to engineer proteins
to rice and make a rice that's more easy
to,
to process.
And a lot of people have benefited from
it greatlY.
And then there's also shit that they
designed that they want to make so that,
uh,
a plant,
certain plants can deal with pesticides.
There's that too.
But there's a,
but they've always done that with
selective breeding,
but they've,
they've,
they've messed with things so that they
deal wIth pesticides better and
unfortunately like a lot of times that
fucks up the environment like bs,
like they've,
they've connected the drop of dropoff in
the population of bees to a couple of
different things.
They say that cell phones are not good
for them.
They're not digging the fact that
there's all these cell phone signals
everywhere that fucks with bees
apparently.
But they can deal with that I guess.
but what's fucking them up is there's
certain pesticides that just wreck havoc
on b communities and if you get a
genetically modified plant and in these
chemicals are involved in that process
and these bees get ahold of these
chemicals or they come into contact with
these chemicals,
it can be deadly to them.
There's,
you know,
this is a real issue with fucking,
with nature,
with we don't know the ultimate
consequences because the world that we
live in is an ecosystem.
It's like everything affects everything.
They say that if aunts died,
if we killed all the aunts and the
planet,
we will be fucked.
Like the whole world would go into
chaos.
It.
Who knows these two?
yeah,
it was.
We need everything.
It's all here for a reason.
You know,
it's all connected and when you have
something that you know,
well it can absorb chemicals better so
we can kill off all these bugs and we
don't have to worry about and we get a
big yield and we can sell that yield,
but it's killing bees like that's.
There's a yin and a yang to everything.
There's a push and a pull to everything
and the more you you dabble with nature,
you're dealing with this unbelievably
complex structure.
The structure of nature so intertwined
and so,
so broad that when you fuck around with
it,
hopefully it has a good effect,
but there's also,
there's going to be the potential for
negative downsides.
That's what I think about gmo.
I think it's.
Look,
if we could figure out a way to make
food that all these poor people would
have nutritious food,
it's super easy to grow and everybody
benefits from it.
Hey,
I'm all for it,
but most of the time when they're
involved in genetically modified foods
are doing it for profit.
They do other things for money.
It's a big part of what it is.
Fucked up.
Yeah.
Because I was like,
we think about money now this now with
dealing carrier.
What's gonna happen next?
You know what I mean?
Well,
there's a lot of people that definitely
don't think about the future.
They just fucking ride that bitch.
Right?
It's like,
why the fuck do we do still use oil?
It a bunch of reasons.
One because we know how to do it and
we'd have the whole systems in place for
oil to change the system and change it
to like solar.
Like everybody,
like la could probably run on solar if
we have.
So it's really a shame that we don't
have solar panels everywhere in la.
The motherfucker is constantly and they
work and it's sunny constantly mean.
It would be definitely more expensive.
It would take awhile to then you also
have to get batteries and the batteries
have to have minerals and those
batteries.
A lot of those minerals come from
conflict areas like the Congo or
Afghanistan,
so it's not all simple,
sweet and clean to have electric power
from,
from solar because you have to have
batteries to store that power.
Otherwise it goes off at night.
You know what about,
what about that nikola tesla?
Dude,
we Buy them.
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
She got fucked.
You know,
we never learned about him,
but he meant that all the,
all the best electrIc electric stuff,
he invented a lot of cool shit,
but he also fell in love with a pigeon.
He was in love with the pigeon before he
died and here's,
I likes to fly pigeon.
I don't think he fucked hIm.
I don't think he fucked anything.
He actually,
one of the quotes,
I can't find this anywhere else,
but I read it once.
I know for sure that he destroyed his
sexuality was the quotes because yeah,
you had some issue with some woman and
it didn't work out and it just destroyed
him.
He couldn't concentrate,
so he's like,
you know what,
I'm done with these balls and just
she's,
hey did.
There's a guy in my gym,
he's a,
he's from New York.
Actually we a scientist,
right?
It looks like a normal guy,
but he's a scientist and he,
he,
he invented this thing,
do I?
Now this company is in the works for
that.
It's like a $20,000,000
deal.
Huge thing,
right?
It's a,
it's a magnet assisted generator.
So,
so once it gets going,
it's perpetual,
not perpetual,
But 10,000
years is how long a magnet last until
the energy to magnet dies.
So it'll,
it'll spend 10,000
years.
Jesus christ.
It's like a fucking huge fucking deal.
It's like,
you know,
twitter is three,
a million or a huge deal and it's.
He says it'll,
it'll,
it'll boost any power plant anywhere
from 70 to 100 percent more power
production,
but it's like a pretty much like the
modern tesla coil.
Like it's like the newest thing.
I actually told him I,
I want to see if we can call them or
somewhere.
He said he would come down and talk to
you,
but it's a,
it's a,
it's a bad ass.
Yeah.
Give me his email address and I'll email
them.
We'll figure it out,
find out what it is.
He told him about it at the gym that
are.
But it's like it's gonna be a real deal
man.
And he says something like that.
There's no.
Because right now we use turbans.
No,
the windmill was created electricity.
The turbines on the waterfall.
Let's tricity the nuclear energy,
but this thing is just fucking magnets
and they spend by themselves and that's
it and it makes electricity
so it just needs something to start it
up.
And then once it starts up they repel
each other and I just keep on moving,
you know,
If it's that easy,
why hasn't someone else figure that out?
Petro emotion and supposedly not
supposed to ever been solved.
It's not perpetual motion.
If you get something to start it up,
if something starts it up,
you know you're gonna need something.
It only last 10,000
years,
which is fucking long enough,
but you got to get it going.
But then once it goes,
it just keeps.
Keeps on moving.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
That's crazy.
So this dude is easy figuring out a way
to sell this.
What would they think?
They're in negotiations with?
Huge,
huge companies.
Be better Fucking be careful.
I was that dude.
I'd hide where I live.
They'll fucking kill him.
Like they shit.
That dude who invented the water card?
The guy who rented the car power.
That was powered by water.
Yeah.
He died in a meeting he had with these
people.
Sid Caesar.
Since caesar.
Just If the guy who invented the water
car died in a meeting with these two
people that were supposed to be
government agents and he was screaming,
they poisoned me,
poisoned me.
That was his last words for you.
Had a attack fucked up,
dude.
That might be a fake room or by the way
sounds fake.
It sounds fake.
It sounds like that other one there.
There you olympics.
Won the olympics.
One was totally fake.
They like to do that lately.
Like to have these websites and just
write fake stories and then not even
funny.
They just fake.
Yeah.
There's a website where people,
you could just add somebody's name to
the last part of it and it will be a
fake,
a hoax death.
Like it looks like a news site and it
just replaces photos.
There's too much on the internet.
The internet,
too much freedom on the government.
When I was at the citadel at the college
I was at because I was a biology major,
so they had some scientists were touring
the country and they were like coming
around to schools and uh,
trying to like tell us stuff,
you know,
what will make us aware.
It was like a team of four scientists
and it was just them and their
adventures.
They're saying these are our inventions
that the government is fucking canned.
We're only four guys,
you know,
imagine how many other things are out
there,
but one guy,
he said,
he invented a carburetor that you can
hook on any car and you're,
I think it's 80 miles a gallon.
Like instantly.
He's like,
oh fuck,
I'm fucking.
He was saying,
well we went for like jam or what?
He couldn't saY.
It was like he thought I saved all this
money.
I'm going to be rich,
blah,
blah.
He says,
the fuckIng government got the patent
candidate,
right?
There's this lady,
she made a clear enamel coat.
He put her teeth one time,
the dentist puts it on the clear coat,
and keith are invincible.
They'll never get a caBbie.
Nothing.
They're like,
it's like a seal.
It seals your teeth.
They bought the patent through the way
away.
Really know the guy invented.
So you know,
cigarettes are addicting,
you know,
but it causes fucking cancer.
One dies.
He invented a molecule that It addicts.
You like nicotine still,
but you just have no cancer.
So the cigarette,
you smoke and you're hooked on it,
but you won't die.
He's like,
oh,
this is the best invention ever.
I'm gonna save all these lives.
And the company that he worked for
bought it and shoved it.
That doesn't sound right.
How is it possible that you could smoke
and not get sick?
Because the,
the,
the molecule event that was just like
nicotine or whatever it was.
It was addictive,
but it was a car.
It wouldn't kill you.
I believe he said that to you,
but I also believe he's full of shit.
I dunno.
Some pretty complicated medicine right
there.
They people would know about the
possibility of that.
These guys were,
there were a team of scientists and
they're coming around like telling us
like we're four guys and like we've
invented this shit.
It's hard when you're dealing with
something that's so long ago too.
And then like,
you know,
you try to like recant the story,
tell the story,
but that was adjusted.
But you know what I mean.
But,
but it's like wait a while.
If you had an enamel coat in her teeth,
you cannot get a cavity then most
answers out of work,
you know,
you know they that the car didn't.
She doesn't want 80 mile per gallon
cars.
You know what I mean?
They don't want that.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know,
back then you hook It on your car and
you're,
you're set.
Well,
the definitely would be a blow back.
There was,
it was definitely a lot of people.
If they're losing money,
if they would lose money,
if something came along that made cars
unbelievably more efficient,
they would need less gasoline.
That would be a fuckload less money.
The amount of money that's spent every
day In this country on fossil fuels.
We can't even wrap our head around that
number.
Crazy.
It's an insane number.
So to get
that out,
it's going to take many generations.
It's going to take a long window of
change or it's going to take one
spectacular invention.
Like the electric car.
Electric cars are cool,
but fuck,
they take a long time to charge up.
They could only go like 300 miles.
It takes like you gotta charge them,
like even if you need rapid charge,
it's a half hour,
so you have to sit in a gas station for
half hour.
Your fucking car charges.
Talked to doing it for my gym.
That guy,
the scientist guy about the cars.
I was like,
yeah man.
Like he says it's a scam though.
He says that the whole car was pretty
much a battery and he says that all the
lead in the shit and the battery is,
it actually ends up being just as bad or
worse for the environment than,
than if you just would have had a car
with gas.
Really.
That's what he says.
But I was like,
fuck.
I thought that was all propaganda dude.
But he says,
no,
it's fucking,
it's not as good as you think it is
going.
Well.
You definitely need minerals.
Knew the same thing is with the um,
with the batteries that you need for
solar generators.
You need minerals to put into the mean
at least in the current technology that
they had used lithium ion.
And that's one of the big discoveries
they found.
Afghanistan was lithium.
Lithium is pretty valuable stuff and
then when they converted it into
batteries like you to get that out of
the ground,
you got to get it out of the ground and
that's so anybody thinks that you got
this completely green,
clean thing because it's made out of
batteries now it's just not using as
much fossil fuel every day.
That's what he was saying.
He said that when you add it up,
but it really isn't all you think is
going to be.
It takes fossil fuel to make a car too.
That's another thing that people aren't
taken into consideration and there's no
tires other than rubber tires.
I mean,
you get,
you gotta use synthetic materials to
make tires.
They haven't come up with a hemp tire
yet.
You know,
until they come up with something that's
absolutely green and biodegradable as a
tire,
you're always going to deal with you
ever see a tire when it gets lit on fire
forever.
Disgusting.
I mean,
that is toxic waste.
That's one of the things they do to
people in Brazil.
There was a thing,
um,
they,
they do what they call microwave you,
they put you inside a row of tires
burning and burn you.
It's because your dna,
it becomes almost impossible to identify
you because you Just get intermingled
with these tires.
It's just a mess.
Yeah.
Gasoline and tires.
It's like a fucked up way to get rid of
a body.
Oh,
that,
that's what people go destroy vehicles
that they want insurance to be destroyed
because the tire's melts so hot.
That will actually bend the whole frame
of the car.
So that way you can do to get your car.
So people are so silly.
Yeah.
So tell me,
mAn,
we were,
we were talking about this,
but we got off the subject.
What did you do the entire year that you
were in solitary?
Like what was your day?
Did you wake up [inaudible]?
Because it was weird.
They were fetus like at um,
for him was breakfast,
right?
So they wake you up,
feed you breakfast,
eating past black guy,
right.
And then you get up again like nine or
10.
Now 10:00
will be lunch.
That's when you use a lot of weird
schedule pick up lunch and then from
that point on I will just read,
I would read from 10:00
AM
until like 11 at night and I take an
hour break to workout.
Wow.
I mean I read the second year I kept
tracking with 117 books.
Wow.
But um,
I mean there's nothing I could have read
way more,
but you will not of books,
you know,
you're out of books.
It's so boring.
I want to come out of myself every other
day for an hour,
you know what I mean?
And then just like a just fucking board
dude.
What is it like to not talk to people
for so long?
I mean,
you,
you talked to.
I mean it's just weird dude.
It's like a to neighborhood.
It's like a fucking time warp because
when you're in there,
the day goes by real slow with like the
months go by quick and then when you get
out it's just like,
it was like,
it was all a dream.
He didn't.
Even if you weren't even in there,
it's weirdly folks through your head.
And then like,
uh,
it was whoa man,
the underfed is so bad.
Do they fucking underfed is bad.
Yeah.
And las vegas real bad.
UH,
I was trying to calculate how much
protein I thought that was getting
today.
And it was like 20,
30 grams did.
Whoa.
And here's,
here's,
I know it was bullshit because this is
vegas.
Especially if it's ending.
He goes better in vegas.
We only got a piece of fruit like twice
a week.
So like we got like an orange like twice
or three times a week.
That's it.
But we're just made with her.
Was it right?
So maybe with a got there,
do hIs,
his two months ends fucking he started
bitching at the,
at the judge,
like they're not feeding me enough to
give me shit free,
blah blah blah,
blah.
All of a sudden,
bam fruit everyday.
Big portions.
All this shit for all of you.
Everyone.
Right?
Because I know why.
I know why.
Because they were scared me.
Whether it's camp was going to have the,
the people that feed us,
you know,
investigating.
Yeah.
You know.
And guess what,
the second he left went away.
Wow.
No shit.
I swear to god.
And I told the,
I told one of the cool god's name and
come here.
I said,
you notice motHerfucker that as soon as
me with her started bitching at court,
now we've got bigger trades and we got
fruit every day.
And then he started chuckling and he
laughed.
He walked away.
But it's like they knew,
they knew what was up.
They were undefeated in the fuck out of
us.
So what it like,
how many calories do you think you get a
day did?
It was,
it was shit I hard to say,
but no more than.
Less than $1,500.
Wow.
It was bad dude.
It was fucking starving all the time.
So it must have been.
Everyone was skinny then?
yeah,
unless you get.
If you had money in the commissary,
you can buy junk food.
They sell chips and bullshit like that.
But that said they don't sound like
healthy options.
Peanuts was the best.
Well,
I,
I love on peanuts,
but um,
and,
but then if the food was bad,
man it was real bad.
That was the worst part is so for a
year,
just bad food by yourself.
Reading books.
Daddy just going crazy in there.
What about,
um,
what does it feel like to not talk to
people for so long?
It's one,
it's a,
it's weird.
You don't know untiL you get out when
you get out of here,
like culture shocked becAuse you know,
you go from no interaction with nothing
to like cars going by,
you know what I mean?
Just like whoa,
you know,
like me,
I take,
I take a medicine for anxiety and
depression.
I take lexapro because got,
I have panic attacks and anxiety.
I'll be honest.
It was like 2006 lexa pros and
antidepressants.
Ssri.
Yeah.
Mostly I take it for anxiety,
[inaudible] I would get panic attacks.
It was just my dad died out.
I would get them and then like I just
battled them all my whole life and try
to like,
oh,
you know,
like I don't want to go to doctor
doctors for postseason.
No medicines for pussies,
you know,
and finally,
actually when avenue was on ultra and
fighter house in the ultimate fighter
house,
like the,
the lack of a,
I was so isolated,
nothing,
do nothing.
It really got me bad and I was having
anxiety attacks on the show and it was
just like I was a mess.
Right.
So when I got the ultimate fighter house
I find say fuck this man,
I'm not,
I'm not gonna pretend to be tough
anymore.
I'm going to go try to get help,
you know.
And that shit made me 95 percent better,
you know,
in a lot of ways.
But when I was in san diego that gave it
to me and they just,
they wouldn't give it to me really?
Yeah.
They fucking want give it to me.
They're dicks.
So the whole year we admitted degas was
worse because I had none.
I had a lot of anxiety in there.
And did you,
when is there like a um,
like a wean off period or did you just
cold cold Turkey?
Cold Turkey.
Me and you get withdrawals.
So like the first,
the first three weeks I was miserable.
Real,
real bad.
Like I don't know,
it was bad.
Then I,
then I,
then I settled down and that was kind of
good.
But I was just,
it was shitty.
It was shitty.
Wow.
So just a year of reading books and
being by yourself.
What about like hugging people and shit?
Yeah.
You see you get no,
no interaction like that.
And even the visits in san diego,
the visits were behind glass so you can
actually see you,
which was a lot better in vegas.
The videos were on like a computer,
like a skype kind of thing,
you know?
So they would come there and they be
there but you couldn't see them on skype
kind of thing and half the time the
phone didn't work good.
Or the screens in orchid it was,
it was really like after a while I just
told the guards I don't want no visits
canceled my visits Because it made it
harder for me.
Like you know,
you watch movies,
like people were like in Vietnam movies,
they're lIke,
like why don't you write me back?
You know,
like,
like I was in the war,
I want to focus on the ward.
I did write back and other families or
whatever I can understand because when I
was there I didn't want any fucking
business.
I didn't want,
I didn't call anybody,
I didn't,
I just sat there and read my books and I
did my,
my jail blogs every,
every week.
Yeah.
I've read those,
had those and I just,
I decided there and just you're in a
bubble man.
It was hard for me because when I was in
jail,
like my,
I was married and my wife got deported
back to Hungary and all this shit.
So like I didn't even get to say
goodbye.
My grandma died when I was in jail and
it was like my grandma was living,
my grandma was living in vegas like
fucking 10 minutes from the jail and I
could even say bias.
SHe was dying of cancer.
She died,
you know?
And it was like,
it was,
it was rough.
It was a rough year last year.
So do you get young kids who might like
look up to you and they might be kind of
going down the same path,
the.
Do you get guys like that coming up to
you for advice and you tell them just
don't go to jail,
man.
Whatever you do,
figure out a way to get out of trouble,
figure out a way to avoid violence.
Yeah.
You kNow,
I do that even in jail,
you know,
I would talk to guys I'm,
I'm not as there for a fight.
And I've talked to other guys like,
you know,
especially the first year I was there
when I was in general population.
Now I try to help them.
Like amen.
You're not going to fucking quit the
drugs if you go get back out and handled
the same friends.
Like this is the bottom line.
You got to quit your friends,
you've got to get new friends and new
environment or you're going to go back.
I don't give a fuck.
So you know what I mean?
Like these guys,
I will say this,
seeing that's my problem is fighting,
right?
If I go to a bar,
you're drunk.
It's not,
I'm not going to look for a fight,
but guess what,
if something happens,
I know it's a bad recipe,
you know,
you're trying your problems,
cocaine,
but when you get out you better not be
around your friends with the cocaine.
So I would tell the guys like,
you know,
it ain't worth it motherfucker.
And these gangs gang bullshit.
I see like young kids who were 17,
they brought state from juvenile hall
fighting a murder case and he was like
17 old kid.
He didn't even do it.
His friend did it,
but he's not going to rack rack.
Do you know he's,
he's in a gang and shit.
But I said many of your friends,
a piece of shit.
He doesn't mean he did it cause you guys
are both.
They both get life,
you know,
because life's ruined.
so I'll tell you.
Oh you young kids,
man,
it ain't worth it man.
Talk to the older guys.
Know I got to tell you,
the older guys always like,
man,
this is bullshit.
I wish I could take my life back,
but it's too late.
So.
And when you're in the wrong
environment,
man,
especially with alcohol,
it's so easy to get in trouble.
I mean that story that you told about
the old man that pushed the tow truck
driver.
And then next thing you know he'S in
jail.
The next thing you know he murdered a
guy in jail and next thing you know he's
probably in jail for life.
Who knows what happened to him because
he couldn't afford a good lawyer.
He was poor.
You know,
we've got a real problem with.
That is a real problem with that
situation,
that particular story that's like this
hard by the book shit.
we,
they don't look at each individual case
as being a separate entity and say,
oh,
these are circumstances that are pretty
unusual.
I see what's going on here.
This guy's not a criminal.
He just overreacted.
You can overreact like that
dude,
you got to go.
I've been in court because we go to
court,
you know,
like they bring the whole bus of us to
go to court sometimes.
And like you watch the judges,
men given out 15 years,
10 years,
like not,
not even looking at but from the paper
10 years.
Like it's like what the fuck.
Like this guy has given out years.
like they don't understand how long that
is,
that they don't care.
They don't care.
They have no.
And sometimes sometimes the guy who
deserve a dude,
but sometimes it's like fuck.
When you heard about that judge in
Pennsylvania that was putting kids in
juvenile detention centers and getting
paid for it,
he was doing it for years.
He just went to jaiL.
They sentenced him to 25 plus years.
He's a fucking judge man.
And he was getting payoffs because of
the same thing we talked about about
privatized prisons,
about prisons making profit off of the
amount of people that they have in them.
Dude,
fucking madness man.
It's fucking so you get out.
All right.
You're,
you're there for a year.
Shit.
Diet.
Fucking no human interaction.
What is your first week like?
So I get out.
And then how long before you get some
pussy?
Well that's the thing.
So I,
when I first got out I was,
I was so like,
oh man,
like I'm like a,
what's it called?
Conceited or whatever.
I had to look good.
I,
my whole life I've been in shape whole
life,
been working out.
so when I got out of jail,
like I feel like insecure.
Like I,
I'm skinny,
I'm like skinny fat,
I just have a shitty body,
a pale,
I feel ugly.
Right?
So I,
I didn't go,
I didn't push it for a month because I
was trying to get decent schaefer's
because I thought I just felt like
insecurity plus the first,
both towns I got out of jail.
The first two weeks were hard man.
Like my anxiety is bad.
Like,
like,
like I didn't get on the lexapro right
away when you got out?
Uh,
yeah.
When I got out I tried it,
I got it right away.
So the first like ngo,
I didn't cry or in jail,
not because I'm tough,
I just didn't cry.
I don't know why even my grandpa died.
I didn't cry and I just sat there and
numb.
Right.
But when I got out the first two weeks I
would cry every night in bed.
What the fuck,
like getting out is so much shit's
hitting at the same time.
And just like,
like when I first walked into the gym
and I started crying,
like,
just like too much emotion,
too much weird from going from no
interaction to bam,
like on the freeway,
this,
that is that going crazy.
It's too much to,
to any sensory overload and I can't even
explain it.
It was just fucking weird.
Really weird.
And I'm like,
dude,
you didn't expect that.
And suicidal too.
Like I was gonna kill me.
Like I want to kill myself.
Really?
Yeah.
And what was,
what was the motivation to kill
yourself?
Like what were you,
what was so upset aBout It?
Just the uh,
your,
you get overloaded with,
with emotion to the.
I don't know,
it's weird that you can't go out.
You can't go from like being in a box to
real life.
They should like gradually,
like adjusting to a halfway house.
I don't know,
something,
something because just it's too much,
too much at one time.
Like now everything's real.
When I was in jail,
nothing's real.
When you're in jail,
it's like a,
it's a fake world man.
It doesn't seem real.
And you get out and it's like that was a
dream and now all of a sudden your wife
really got the port at your grandma's
really did.
Your grandpa was really miserable as
fuck.
Dan wants to die,
you know,
like you got to pay bills now.
TheY want me to find paul daily right
off the bat in three months.
What the fuck?
You know,
I'm like too much stress and I use,
you know,
you,
you started going crazy dude.
And like you just feel like miserable.
The hardest part about jail for me was
getting out the first few,
few weeks.
That's a crazy thing is.
So this is the door.
This is your beltour contract.
They wanted you to fight daily.
Three weeks,
three months after you got out of jail.
Yeah.
Because what they did was they did a fan
fight vote when I was in jail.
Me daily,
saunders and lima and like the fans vote
and whoever wins the top two bolts is
going to win.
I said,
if you want to say I'm going to limit
the dumb ass,
I'm going to win.
So no you're not.
I said,
I'm going to fucking win the vote,
dude.
No one else is gonna.
Get more posts,
man.
I'm telling you dude,
I don't want to.
I don't want to fight.
I don't wanna fight.
None of those guys.
My first fight after three months,
three months ago,
you're not going to win and do fucking.
I wouldn't buy like 10 times as many
opposed to anyone else.
It was like me versus daily was number
one.
Then we didn't meet her honors meters,
lima.
I was like,
fuck.
Okay.
So don't find daily first.
Like whatever.
Right?
Then what do they say to you when you
bring that up?
Like I told you,
pitch.
I was like,
told you.
They're like,
fuck man.
Like you,
you killed it.
Yeah.
I'm like,
but it wasn't like,
it wasn't even a.
And then was a tournament.
So trauma is three fights.
So I was like,
it was the first finance.
So fucked man.
I'm getting the first.
It's like basically you got your number
two top seeds.
Most popular guys fighting in the first
fight for at least amount of money
because you know,
graduate,
it's like 77,
the first bite,
50 and 15.
Then the rest.
So it's like we're losing the first
round.
I make seven grand.
It's like neither one of us want to make
seven grand.
Like fuck,
that's so crazy.
Seven grand for a professional mma fight
on television.
Yeah.
But I'm glad.
Was the standard the same thing in ufc
too,
you know,
with everyone for lower.
But yeah,
for anyone,
you know.
But either way like put the tournaments
good because a tournament should be
seated.
So the two guys,
the two best guys should fight at the
end is not in the beginning.
No.
So it was like fuck.
Anyway,
I'm training,
getting back in shape and a month until
I tore my acl.
So I teaR my acl.
not a,
not a bad thing all the way through,
but the tear partial and I fractured my
tibia tibia plateau.
It's like,
fuck,
so I just got out and now this happens
and I blamed on the nutrition.
I think my body,
my bones were still leached from,
from that whole year of starving and bad
nutrition in it.
I've never been hurt before.
You know it right away.
Bam.
My tee shirt.
It didn't help.
It didn't help being out of shApe like
that and force yourself to get trained
in a high level.
I tear that then.
No,
no,
no.
I started at a fixer.
Really?
How bad is it?
Buckle.
Not as buckle.
It's pretty strong.
It was a partial tear.
It's partially.
Yeah,
it wasn't bad.
It wasn't habit in any way to do
prolotherapy poor.
I'm poor,
you know,
a guy got really poor,
like when I got out of jail was living
in my students garage,
like the garage,
like,
you know,
and I was driving this piece of shit car
and like I was broke as fuck,
you know,
so I just sucked it up and uh,
I feel it.
How do you make money then?
I don't remember.
That made money.
So how you been fighting for?
How long have you been fighting for
beltour now?
Um,
since,
since the last year.
So then after I fixed my knee,
I went and filed a blossom aina first
fight back.
It killed in a Second round with
crucifix.
Then,
um,
then I went to the tournament and I
fought a skype on anderson who's from
China?
White guy.
The guy beat him jailbird it was dick.
She has things like me,
like I don't ever talk shit about my
opponents like outside,
like mannequins,
but usually when I fIght I come,
I'll fight,
I'll fight your hardest.
I can,
but I don't,
I'm not gonna say shit.
But if you started the nightmare
personally and I don't have,
to me you cross land,
cross land and that's it.
I don't play the fucking bullshit game
of like,
oh,
it's for sure for sure.
That motherfucker like if you want to
play the game,
it's really for me.
What do you thInk about the situation of
bell tour?
That I thought was really strange was
the chandler situation,
the chandler and alvarez situation and
then the aspirin thing.
Like how did they let him go when he's
the champ?
You know what a like bellow tour.
It is awesome.
The creamy good.
Yeah.
I liked him a lot,
right?
I think an aspirin,
I think really.
He's a nightmare dude.
He's a fucking nightmare.
He's invincible.
He's boring and no one wants to see him
fight the truth and they created a
monster.
You know what I mean?
So he wanted to go good.
Get the fuck out of here.
It was like,
it was almost like they let alvarez go.
Right.
Why is marketable?
Because he fights wild asking.
No one wants it.
He's done so many fans and the ufc
didn't want him either because he's one
of you would have asked.
She goes in and beats everyone.
I'm I want to see it.
Yeah,
he won't.
He has no hands.
But what if we did.
Then you got this fucking guy,
that women prior to that,
when lynn was invincible,
right.
He lost one time to fucking dave trail.
They fired him because they're like,
thank god we got rid of matt lindland
because he was.
He was not marketable.
Found eco vitaly too.
And knocked himself out.
Remember he went to lateral,
dropped him still.
He didn't deserve yet fired yet.
But they wanted rid of them.
You know what I mean?
Suplex.
They want to rid of them.
Yeah,
no,
for sure.
So like not as koreans didn't know.
Massland asking fucked up.
he should have stayed in builder.
Now what's he gonna do now is going to
fight in China.
Nfc,
right?
Yeah.
But is there any more?
I think they're paying them good though.
They have to be,
but like he's out of the most exposure
is obviously the fight in the ufc belt
was the second most exposure that you
can get.
What else?
You.
No one's gonna watch.
Who's going to watch?
Man?
Me personally,
I'm a purist and I feel like if there's
a guy like ben asking that can hold you
down and dry hump you for five rounds,
that's what he can do.
Like if that guy should be able to fight
and if he could take guys down and give
them the buggies and elbow him and punch
him in the head and,
and hold everybody down for five rounds,
then that's reality.
That's reality.
You can't.
You can't hide that.
You can't not have that guy fight
because you're worried he's going to be
boring.
He's doing everything according to the
rules.
Like you can't like penalize a guy
because you don't particularly like his
style and that's my issue that I have
with every organization does.
I think they're crazy.
I would never do it.
If I was running bella tour,
I would have given the guy who's fucking
money.
He's the champ.
Nobody could beat him.
It's kind of interesting.
you've got a boring champ.
You've got a guy like douglas lema who's
just fucking beast.
Smashing people.
Then was fish too.
Vicious,
vicious dude.
Takes him down like nothing.
Cookie sandwiches,
bitch pizzas.
That lean was a huge giant ashlyn.
Small farewell walter,
and they asked her to take some down.
No problem man,
handle them,
but it all comes down to to the ratings.
Dude.
I don't give a fuck.
I really think that the ratings are very
important,
but the product has to be pure.
As soon as you.
You fuck with things like you remember
what elite ecc was?
Standing people out.
They'd go down for like 15 seconds.
Stand the most bullshit.
They stood up.
Big country.
He had andre arlovski inside control and
he's Working on komora and they stood
him up.
He had this,
he had the double wrist lock.
He had the whole thing up there and they
stood them up,
but I was like,
out is this side control.
You're standing.
The guy up,
they still dudes up from the mount guys
are full mountain.
They stood them up.
It's crazy.
They wanted to be almost no ground time.
They want almost no ground time,
but when you do that,
you change in what mma really is.
Mma is a fight and in those five minutes
you have some specific rules.
You can't kick in the groin.
Camp poke in the eyes can pull guys here
go.
I mean,
you know what the rules are.
Don't kick it down upon it.
Everything else you could do and if a
guy like asking could just take dudes
down and get on top of him and punch him
in the face and they can't do shit about
it.
I mean he's winning within the rules.
He was winning.
you got to let them win.
You got to let them win.
You got to let them try to win this.
The only,
the only reason I could think why they
didn't keep them and why the use of why
didn't you want them?
Listen.
If the ufc took him and then he fights
johny hendricks and gets put into
night-night land.
That's fantastic.
That's interesting.
Will see.
I think a scared.
Maybe he won't.
He could.
It's possible.
It's totally possible.
If you look at his record.
Well one guy gave him a hard time.
Jay here on game.
A real hard Time with this.
We can wrestle inbox.
He could wrestle any.
I don't think.
I think hendrix would would have killed
them at cost check.
I think we're killing anyone that
anyone's going to wrestle and punch,
but I want to see it.
I want to see it too.
I want to see a guy be effective until
he can't be effective anymore.
Like when people said like they asked me
like,
were you sad when anderson silva got
beat?
I was like,
no,
I'm never sad when anybody gets beat.
I'm sad if someone gets hurt.
I was more sad the second fight to see a
dude fuck his leg up like that.
But I want to see a guy like anderson
silva who looks invincible,
get a guy,
figured that out.
That's the evolution of the game.
It's all about that.
And if it was,
you know,
whoever it was,
whether it was vittorio was chris
weidman,
whoever it is.
I like to see these guys figure it out.
I like to see a guy salva guy,
but I mean that's the only reason that I
can say why you sit in silence.
I don't see it.
I mean,
I don't understand what it is.
I think it was also the issue that they
felt that a bell tour was playing games
and like bella tour was,
you know,
like they might know,
oh we we cast off are.
We didn't even want them anymore.
The ufc took them,
ha ha,
they're dummies.
That guy's boring.
And when bjorn was saying that,
I'm not a fan of his style,
you know,
like the guys affected.
But he's kind of boring.
Like I don't find them boring as a
person who grapples.
I get fascinated by how the fuck he does
it.
I don't know why I want to roll with the
guy because I want to feel it because I
don't get it.
I mean I see him manhandled dudes and
I've,
I've wrestled dudes that are real.
You know what Eric Bradley is,
but high level wrestler.
He was trading at 10th planet once we
were doing these neon belly drills.
That dude threw me off him like I was a
fucking pillow like this.
There's certain dudes are that creepy
wrestling strength,
you know?
And when I was on the bottom when he was
doing neon belly on me,
I wasn't going nowhere.
Man.
That's where I was staying.
And he wasn't any bigger than me.
Like maybe 10 pounds bigger than me.
There's something weird that those who
like olympic level,
high level grapplers have fucker was
with yesterday,
the olympian,
silver medalist dude,
he was on top of me,
bro.
He's smaller than me first of all,
and I'm strong.
He felt strongly as fuck.
Retarded,
like just so strong,
like a rock.
It was something else.
It's Your whole life.
Just grappling.
Those guys develop freaky strain.
He just like,
he just went out there so he could hold
me there,
but I couldn't.
I'm good at getting up.
I was like,
fuck thiS guy off me,
dude.
Yes.
Stuck.
I mean,
you know.
Yeah.
There's some freaky dudes like that man
that have that freaky grapplers trying
to.
Obviously aspirin has it beCause if you
look at his body,
I mean,
he doesn't look like a bodybuilder.
Oh,
it doesn't look strong and he looks like
an athlete,
but he doesn't look like your guy who
even does as much strength and
conditioning.
He's,
he's,
uh,
he's uh,
one of them freaks,
you know,
he just ragdoll people.
It's weird to watch.
I was really looking forward to him when
they,
when they said that that bell toward was
not going to sign them.
I was looking forward to that guy beat
in the ufc champion,
the ufc,
him and robbie lawler.
I would want to see if robbie gets
stopped that tank down.
I want to see what the fuck.
What happens to him when he gets hit by
a demon.
You know what if he gets in there with
carlos condit and you know,
and he can't.
If conduct could stop the shot and he's
got to stand up with them.
I want to see him against like the real
high level guys.
Now there's going to be fighting dudes
you never heard of in China,
you know?
Yeah.
Maybe.
Okay.
You'll fight it.
Okay,
so he's over there,
right?
Yeah.
Without it was wrestling to death.
Do you feel like there's enough options?
I mean there's bella tour this ufc and
then there's not this world series of
fighting and then is a wfa.
There's a few other ones or what is the
rfa rfa ad sources organization.
I mean,
to me the only legit organizations as
you've seen bill her,
like roaches fridays is legit,
but I hasn't been,
I don't think it's going to last.
How long is gonna be around,
you know,
these things pop up and then he
disappeared and I heard the pain kind of
too much and I don't know,
I just don't know if they haven't really
going to last.
You know whaT I'm saying?
They're on nbc late at night,
but I heard they,
they pay for their spot and shit.
I don't know if it's true though because
the nbc is not promoting it,
you know what I mean?
To me,
if you're not,
you got to be in belt or a ufc one.
Bad ass too.
But you get no exposure.
You can't get sponsors because no one's
going to see the fight.
You know what I mean?
So you got to be on american tv so
you've got to be in either use your
built or and to me like fucking a I am.
I'm happy at bell tour because they gave
me freedom dude.
Like I know goddamn well the people like
would you ever go back to the ufc?
Would I have liked to do?
See the question.
Doesn't matter.
That doesn't matter because guess what?
I'll be fired everY week.
You know what I mean?
Like it doesn't matter.
Like just for your blowjob tweets.
Yeah,
I couldn't do shit.
I'll be fired.
So it doesn't matter if I would like to
use that doesn't.
I don't want to care about it right now.
What I want to do,
I want to fight for to her and I'm going
to win them and do good.
And now I'm gonna start this side
business with mike,
with my navy seal friends and the tee
shirt company.
And that's it.
I do alpha male shit.
Tee shirts,
which is very funny.
I love those sharp tongue in cheek
there.
Funny.
We know why.
It's because all these fires make the
mistake of making a t shirt with like
war machine on it,
right?
Not everyone knows who I am,
dude.
And not everyone likes me.
So for years,
my fucking,
my little profile on my twitter and
everything says all of a sudden instead
of like ufc belt and he says,
I do alpha male shit.
That's it.
Right.
So I said,
I'll make sure it,
that way guys will see it and they'll be
like,
they don't need to know who the fuck I
am.
I don't care about me but by the shirt
because he liked what it says.
You know,
I saw way more if I made a trip,
said warm,
I wouldn't sell it.
Not nearly as much.
I saw hundreds of these.
That's funny.
You know what I mean?
It's a smart move.
It's a lot of dudes who want to pretend
to be alpha.
Yeah.
And you know,
and like a body's wanting to do this.
I want to fight and be able to do these
shirts.
And me and my,
my navy seal buddies were getting a
government contract to we're,
we're,
we're building a whole curriculum dude.
So it's three seals,
me and bruny and we're building a me and
brittany or putting on navy seal gear
and we're going to wrestle with it.
And shit,
we're going to actually the vulnerable
brand new curriculum from start to
finish and we're going to.
We're getting government contracts to
train seals and green berets around the
country.
That's a great idea.
And it's going to be fucking lucrative
dudes.
Brandon wolfe from you remember him.
He was an ex silly fight.
The ufc,
he's doing a similar thing on the east
coast,
but they did obviously they did it where
seals method moves and then they had
brandon since he fought to help them
teach it.
So we're doing the opposite.
We're going to have us or the shit and
the event moves and we're going to teach
it,
but it's going to be like it's never
been done before.
And we already have like my buddy has
all the government contracts so it could
be a thing where if it gets big enough,
it can be where we can hire out other
fighters that are done fighting because
a lot of us don't have shit to do.
Dude.
Like we don't have a backup if you're
not.
If you had the champion that you didn't
make enough money to have a backup plan.
So if I can make fucking 150 grand a
year,
training seals and green berets this
hand,
the hand shit and then if it gets too
big and we could hire fucking this guy
and that guy that,
you know what we've done fighting come
work for us,
it will be trained in the moves that we
could do it.
That's a smart thing to.
Because there's some,
there's some specialists in like unarmed
combat when it comes to removing guns
from people and removing knives from
people.
There are some specialists but outside
of that,
most of their hand to hand combat shit
is bullshit.
It's not real.
It's not going to work.
Like I was watching the show the other
night,
I was watching the sportsman's network
at late at night.
They have like the self defense
scenarios.
Like a guy got attacked in an elevator
and he's controlling this guys arm and
then he pulls his gun out and shoots the
guy after he's controlling this guys
arm.
And I'm like,
why is that guy just standing there like
he's not gonna you not gonna control a
guy's arm like that.
If a guy knows how to fight,
what about his other arm?
You ain't doing shit about this arm.
You just.
There's so many facts.
What if he moves?
What if he pulled his arm out?
What if he kicks you in the dick?
Like there's a lot of shit going on.
Like what you should know,
and this is what I was on opie and
anthony wants to.
They used to have this dude that worked
for them was this fake karate guy who
was talk all this mad stupid shit about
you know their sport and then there's
what works on the street.
Like no dummy.
This is what works.
What works with trained killers that
works on everybody when you,
when your shit works on anderson silva,
your shit works on everybody.
What did that.
The thing is like know I've been at,
I've been trading a long time,
you know,
like a new gal coming.
He's like,
oh my god.
Like right now I could poke your eyes
out.
I should poke him.
Okay.
You can try to poke them like,
you know what I mean?
Just try.
Just try and you can't motherfucker.
Because if I'm on the mountain,
you can't reach my eyes and I can read
yours.
I'll poke your fucking eyes and if you
in my garden you can reach my eyes
either because I'm going to have.
You're not going to get my eyes try
biting through my calf.
So said that once.
Yeah.
You don't fight through your calf.
You try to arm bar but you won't hurt.
That will break your fucking arm.
Can you bite through a steak?
If I gave you a fucking giant ham like
ham with it?
It hasn't been cooked yet.
You think you can bite through that.
You could hurt it.
It'll be out cheat.
But in that field,
good.
That's the whole thing is like,
all right,
well now usually I pokes with youtube
motherfucker.
If you can learn how to mountain one
night can really pull through as good.
And that's the thing we will street
fighter like won't work.
Street fighting is all who's willing to
go farther.
So like maybe like we're fighting and
then you know,
if you want to,
if you want to try to head with me or
bite me,
he's asking to scare me.
I'm disengaged.
Or I'm like,
oh mother,
motherfucker,
and I'm going to do it too.
You know what I mean?
So it was always like,
who goes through this farther?
You know,
how serious are you willing to get.
You know what I mean?
That's,
that's.
You remember those felony fights.
There's one of them where a dude held
the guy down.
He was biting his face.
It was so fucked up.
He's holding him down into his scree and
biting his face.
The guy just giant bite marks on his
face and the guy quit actually do a bit
his face.
He was like,
what the fuck man?
He's like,
hey,
didn't say I can't bite your face.
He goes,
how far are you willing to go?
Dude,
go,
yeah.
You always hear stories about some dude
in some town,
a bit,
some dudes nose off.
You're like,
jesus christ knows off,
but you're right about those guys.
They don't know.
My friends are seals and they're like,
don't do that.
They said they thought they thought it
was.
Don't shoot the fuck out of you had a
hand,
you know that they don't know shit,
so if we can invent a curriculum that
it's legit because all,
they're never going to be in a fight,
but if they're going through a hallway
with a gun and someone don't talk about
doors grabbed was when the tangled up.
They need to be able to defend
themselves.
Ready real quick.
You need to know how to do that and
that's something that for the longest
time before the ufc came around really
before nma came around,
people didn't really know what was the
stuff that worked because how many times
do you get in a fight in an elevator?
We got to pull your gun so dudes would
be inventing a bunch of shit that could
work.
And then from here I'm controlling his
arm.
He's,
he's in my position for me to land up
devastating elbow and from here he's
done.
Like if there's not,
that's why I wasn't hungry.
Once visiting my family and I trained
them,
I was hungry and I find that good human
train and I found another gym and it was
like these fucking japanese akita kind
of guy and he was showing me shit like
for like an hour just twisting it,
like he was like showing me stuff,
but I'm letting them do it.
I'm like,
fuck it.
This shit is bad ass.
I'm going to maybe said maybe it does
kind of work.
That.
And we wrestled was fucking never once
was I ever in anything.
Not one thing I didn't even have to
defend.
One thing was just it doesn't work.
It doesn't fucking work.
And somebody told me that to quito is
really effective.
You just have to have a true aikido
master.
I'm like,
well,
get an aikido master to fight in the
octagon.
I would love to see it.
I'd love to see a guy just stand there.
Just flip people effortlessly.
Have them sore.
It worked.
Yeah.
Like we're kids.
We watched steven seagal and van damme.
I wish that shit.
What was the best?
That's the best.
It's fun,
but it just isn't,
you know.
But that's the most important thing
about,
about mixed martial arts is that we know
now more about martial arts than people
did 20,
30 years ago.
We just know more for,
for a fact,
we know what's more effective.
Because know back in the old days,
everyone gets by with like,
they don't have to prove it.
Had the belt.
That's it.
This is the best,
you know,
I'm the teacher.
You stand still.
I'm sure they'll move.
You don't spoil the fucking teacher.
You know,
like,
you know,
I met my,
a beer at your sheet.
Have tried choking me on track and
trying to get him.
We're fighting all day long.
He's my teacher were fighting.
No other martial art.
Do you really fired teachers?
Happier teachers.
Sometimes you know,
any bravo goes to town with his
students.
And I've seen him get tapped by guys by
black belts are brown belts or what have
you because he takes chances and it'll
fight five guys in a row and he's
exhausted.
That's what's called training.
I mean,
that's what it's.
That's what it's about.
Practice.
That's where you want to lose.
Yeah,
exactly.
And if you're afraid to lose,
then you're afraid to get better.
If you're afraid to get better,
you're going to be stagnant and you're
always going to be.
You're always going to shy away from
rolling with anybody that can tap you.
There's a difference between people that
don't understand,
that they've never trained before.
If you've never trained before you,
you'll,
you'll never understand that the correct
mentality,
the correct mentality is like marcello
garcia,
like has the best statement about that.
It's like you have to open up your game
in the gym.
That's the only way to get better
because you have to worry about,
you know,
you have to give yourself the potential
to get tapped.
Don't,
you're not going to be able to type of
guy.
But if you do,
you figure just tap,
just tap and move on.
That's like barrett,
barrett,
small,
just fucking 35.
He's a bad motherfucker though.
And he's a maniac.
Barrett is a fucking dick.
The personality to the core,
his drug is introduced.
I mean,
he's in there three,
four times a day,
all day long.
He's a maniac.
He,
he gets hurt.
You'll tapers out onto himself and still
really,
he's a maniac with barrett.
Take a day off.
He won't.
He'll blindfold ourselves sometimes in
rural.
Wow.
He just uses a maniac.
He's a maniac.
And uh,
he always wants to put himself and make
it harder for them,
you know?
And he's little and he's like,
fuck,
he's so small.
We can just get them.
But you can't because he's a super
technical though.
He's really fun to watch too,
you know,
she does a good guy to learn from my bed
to.
Oh yeah.
And he's,
he's like one of the most humble guys.
He'll see a white belt,
like do something weird.
Like,
hey,
what the fuck?
What did you just do?
Like,
it wasn't a move,
but at the bears then it'd be better
with like,
he doesn't care if he's learned to
brandon.
We've invented yourself and your,
your first day he'll try it.
He don't care.
He has no ego at all.
That smart guys experience.
Well that's a good attitude man.
Because you remember there was like a
big resistance to a lot of the
traditional guys with a lot of new
stuff.
Was coming along,
a lot of guys were saying,
you don't need it.
All you need is just straight.
Great jokes,
but there was so many new moves and
people were like dark jokes and all this
shit that people didn't accept for a
while.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You do japanese neck ties.
You have to do japanese neck times.
It's when you can't get the doors.
If you can't go all the way through and
get the doors,
you get it and he's cinch up here and
you tuck the guy's head into your chest.
You roll over them this way and you hook
a leg and crank.
It is a nasty neck crack.
It's obviously not london.
Bravo's really good at that.
The japanese japanese neck tying guess.
Yeah,
peruvian necktie,
japanese net cranked,
whatever it's called.
It's a nasty move.
Instead of completing the doors,
instead of getting it all the way and
sinking sensation it like this.
Sometimes it's hard to get all the way.
Yeah,
sometimes.
Yeah.
With long arms.
Guys.
How'd you.
How those little t rex arms,
but guys like roger gracie,
you know they have that advantage.
Damien maia want 70,
you know,
he's got a good long frame at one 70.
He's an interesting guy at one 70
[inaudible].
There was a guy that like,
I never thought he was gonna be able to
cut that weight.
Like that's a,
that's a big dude for 170 pounds.
He guys like Nathan Moore court tool.
I couldn't live with Kuwait.
He apparently was walking around and
like one 85 when he was fighting at one
85 or was.
He looks so big.
I never seen him personally,
but he looks huge while he's muscular,
you know.
But apparently he never really cut much
weight at all and fought at one 85.
That dude,
they,
you know,
there's people to talk about him from
the time when he was coming up and enter
into the ufc about how fucking good he
was before he got into the ufc back when
he was fighting in strikeforce or buy
back even before then that uh,
he was always sparring with like big,
big heavy guys though.
Like he would spar with shane carwyn and
they came up at the same gym.
So he'd be in there guy fighting at one
70,
one 85 flight and shane fucking car when
it to 65 and they'd be going to war with
each other on a regular basis.
I've been a fight like the waterways.
Nothing.
Yeah,
you're going to hit me.
I get hit by a car when everyday and not
that they mean he's also taking those
shots and like a guys who know him think
that probably contributed to his demise
all chin.
He was it.
Yeah.
Because you know those dudes that trevor
whitman's dudes,
you can't spar with them.
Big guys.
I mean like unless they're really,
really controlled.
But even like,
um,
I was probably like ray sefo and like a
couple of guys that could towards that
are big,
but they're going soft.
But even though I'm going soft dude it
fucking,
they hit you.
You know what I mean?
They checked your kik for knees or even
like needs like that wire they kick.
You know what I mean?
Even even,
even a soft heavyweight keeps you in the
leg soft and it lands that weight.
It's still heavy and it still hurt your
leg more than any wall to where ever,
you know,
I stay away from the heavyweights unless
they're super,
super controlled.
Yeah,
that's smart.
That's how it all you guys get back.
Injuries to rolling with heavy weights
to get twisted up and gets sprawled on
rehab.
One time I fucking shot on gabriel.
Gonzaga squash me like a book.
Do you know what I mean?
Yeah.
piece huge and moves good.
And he's a giant dick guy when he walks
onto the scale when gonzaga is different
than anybody else in the ufc.
When he gets on the platform,
you feel like the weight of just his.
He's like dense,
like stone,
like he's mad stone,
but he's a dude that trains all the time
and ludlow,
Massachusetts.
He's not treating them like real good
guys out there.
You know,
he's got massive potential.
I mean jujitsu world champion,
bad ass jujitsu,
knockout power.
But he's like a step behind the,
the really the very best guys as I felt
that,
that the last thing on the uc did about
them.
They followed them around.
But it's cool though,
you know,
you see his,
his life there is really good.
Obviously it's got a nice gym.
The people love him,
you know,
he's a great jujitsu coach too.
He's a nice guy and he's very,
very nice guy.
I remember,
I remember one time I was at wec wins.
He came up to me.
He's like,
hey man was.
It was close after I filed j rock.
He was like,
that was a good fight.
And I was like,
fuck.
That was awesome.
Like I was like,
you mother fucker,
you if I was good with crooked when you.
That was crazy.
I mean like,
but it was to have them say that it was
maybe not all of them.
Like,
oh,
I love him now.
He's a very nice night.
His knock out cro.
Cop was the all time greatest head kick
knock out ever was plus because like it
was a little.
How is he going to win the last one?
all the lists of lists.
His head kick.
Yeah,
that's croak.
I was fucking move.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like you're never going to invent guests
that move.
He had kicked the guy who's responsible
for more head kick,
highlight reel knockout than anybody.
like when you watch a cro,
cop and pride career was head kicked in.
What happened to him?
Why do you not do good in the ufc?
Did a lot of questions.
Juice could be that.
Could it be juice?
Could be punishment.
Maybe the amount of punishments.
Body took all those fights or fate or
the fights with nogueira fights with.
I mean think about how many guys who
fought took a lot of fucking hard hard
fights because it was scary.
He was a monster in his first fight in
ufc.
Eddie sanchez,
right?
Yeah.
And like theY told eddie,
eddie eddie knew was going to lose.
We didn't even like you didn't do shit
that he really,
you know what I mean?
Not much.
He definitely didn't look like the same
cro cop.
He never did ever say,
but it could just be that it was the end
of the run.
you know what I mean?
Guys,
just they can only keep it up for so
long.
Like you want to keep it up for so long,
you know,
he was a great,
great,
great fighter.
When he won the pried open wait grand
prix man,
he was a motherfucker back then when he
knocked out vandelay,
the cro cop that knocked out vandelay
was one of the baddest motherfuckers
ever because he had like,
he first fought vandelay.
He didn't know shit about the ground
game and they had like a weird first.
The first fight was like weird rules,
like they only go to the ground for like
30 seconds or something like tide family
up and hang out with,
hang on but wouldn't even be standing
up.
He didn't.
It wasn't free to uncork shots because
he was still worried about the
wrestling.
But the second fight he had his take
down defense down.
He had a good spa at the end and he lit
vandelay up like a christmas tree.
That was one of the best,
the best performances of his career.
It's the second fight with vandelay,
but yeah man,
who knows.
I mean every fighter,
they got a window.
You got a window of time where you could
perform at that level,
you know,
and when you're 37,
38,
39,
it's just slowly winding down and then
that's it.
There's not much left after that.
You
know,
these guys that did perform at that
super high level was vandelay and pride.
I think about that.
Vandelay was never the same.
Vandelay
no was easy.
We,
yeah,
he was still.
He was still pretty good though.
Pretty good pride.
It was crazy.
Well,
he was dominant and pride.
that's the difference.
He's still wild in the ufc.
like he's still beat kyung lee.
Yeah.
But then he gets knocked out by leaving,
you knoW,
it was weird.
Fucked up.
Each tried to go to war with leaving.
You can't stay in the pocket believe
because he can take it,
leave and can take it any.
The motherfucker hits hard.
Chris [inaudible] left hand is a,
a battering ram and motherfuckers got a
real hard lefthand is a matter of him
being able to hit you like uriah hall
fight.
He just couldn't catch.
Hall hall was just too good,
but vandelay went chin to chin with
them.
Well,
theY're the same style.
That why is.
Yeah,
but you know,
like vandelay is still like the brian
stann fight was a great fight.
Still capable of putting on great
fights.
It's just not the same vandelays the
vandelia beat like,
like,
or like I'm quinten jackson or the
vandelay that beat sakuraba or the
vandelay,
the beat henderson the first fight and
he was a destroyer.
He was a scary fucker.
it was.
But it might've been a little bit help
there.
Might have heard a little bit.
They had to.
They all know they do,
but I know they do it,
but it's like what happened?
What I think happens is that some
fighters,
if your first fight is on juice,
then you mentally are dependent on it.
Yeah.
I think the guys that can't perform
without are those ones that they always
had it,
but I think the guys that fight a lot of
times without it and then having,
having and then have,
they can do either way.
You know,
some guys that they've done it from day
one,
then they rely on the juice.
You know what I mean?
Well,
we only have a couple minutes left,
but I want to ask you one thing about,
because this is like the hot topic now
in mma is testosterone replacement.
These guys that are like 29 years old
and replacing that testosterone and
there's a real issue now because
vittorio is going to fight chris
weidman,
they're going to fight in the United
States and they're going to fight in
vegas,
which is a really hard place to get a
testosterone exemption,
especially if you tested positive for
juice,
which tour has in the past,
so he might not get a testosterone use
exemption,
which is fucking crazy because he's been
fighting at this insane level for the
last year.
The bisping fight.
Luke rockhold fight the last.
Dan henderson fight me.
It looks like a fucking demon.
I mean The new veto on testosterone
replacement looks like a fucking demon,
but what is gonna happen to him if he
asked to get off of it,
the fight weinman.
See,
here's the thing with testosterone and
steroids is that,
so say that guy abused it when he was
young,
which be to probably dig back in the
day.
I think for sure too long when you're
young.
Well guess what?
You never came off.
He never fucking did a right.
Your balls turn off and they'll turn
back on.
So now he may be young but his balls
don't work.
So he now he needs this therapy for
really,
really does.
So if you don't let them have it,
you're hurting him.
But at the same time other guys,
maybe they just
do because they want to juice.
So then they get a bullshit doctor to
say,
hey man,
you're a fan.
Give me,
give me this prescription.
You know,
so it's a fucked up thing.
I don't know like,
but in the end of the day,
like if a doctor prescribes it,
dr has a lot,
is supposed to have.
The last rule was a doctor.
So you know,
doctors are,
you know,
they're supposed to be infallible and
like honest and stuff and you know,
we all know that no one is,
but some guys need a man because some of
the guys that they abuse steroids and
are younger and now they have to have
it.
Yeah.
But their argument is that those guys
shouldn't be allowed to fight because in
doing so,
your natural hormone levels drop during
training camp because you train hard and
you breaking down your body.
It's natural for your hormone levels to
drop.
But these guys are,
their hormone levels are not dropping
because they're keeping them at a
consistent level.
If they have to take twice the amount of
an unnatural testosterone in order to do
that,
they're still doing that.
And so they have an unfair advantage and
training camp by taking that.
And I think that's a good argument man.
It's a good argument.
It's tough.
But I think every sport juices period,
a lot of them do every sport,
you know,
and not every guy there,
he's probably every sport dude's juicing
football,
baseball.
He give a shit what works exactly.
And people are always going to try to
find a way to juice and cheap.
So you know what I mean?
It's just a fascinating situation when
you've got veto who's streaking,
who's looked better than ever,
but now he's going to have to fight
weidman.
He might not get a testosterone use
exemption.
Kids real weird,
right?
Yeah.
It's like a.
I don't know.
You can't say yes.
The one that probably didn't know that
next fight.
That's why it's not fair either.
Got to say.
All right man,
if you're on the sheet,
you guys can't fight no more.
Well,
he's only been fighting in Brazil.
That's the craziest way.
It's been fighting in Brazil for the
last.
Like in Brazil,
the.
They'll let him fight on pcp.
We will get a new pcp prescription for
vito.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
He's a.
He's a fucking hero over there.
But yeah,
that's a.
That's a tough subject then.
It is a tough subject because I would
like to see him at this level,
the level that he fought.
Dan henderson.
I would like to see him fight weidman
and it might very well be that the only
way he could reach that level is on trt.
So I dunno.
It's going to stop testing.
Fuck it.
But you take lexapro,
take lexapro.
And you'd take lexapro.
Why you fighting all throughout your
camp?
Oh yeah.
Well now if they said that there's an
advantage that you don't get anxiety
where everybody else is freaking out and
they all get anxiety.
Do you think,
do you think there's anything to that?
Um,
I still get anxiety,
but I mean everyone before the fights.
Nervous.
Right?
Because you want control your nerves in
some way.
Yeah.
Well here's the thing,
I still get nervous,
but before I was way more interesting,
I should have been because I had,
I had a,
I have anxiety and panic attacks so it
manages my nervousness to where I should
be.
I'm a normal nervous instead of a
retarded nervous,
you know what I mean by not back there
like this.
Like totally like,
you know what I mean?
It's still nervous like any other fight,
but not like I was before my medication,
you know,
it doesn't make you tailspin.
No.
But in saying tHat most of fighting is
mental,
big part of it is mental.
Isn't that an advantage to take
something like that?
Uh,
for,
for example,
if I said that they said I can't take it
no more,
it was thought it would fit with me
because I've been,
I've been relying on it,
you know,
I,
I would not,
not for fighting.
I rely on it for life,
you know what I mean?
So it would fit me a lot for me,
But,
uh,
I don't,
I'm not sure what it would do too.
If you're a normal person and he took
it.
I'm not sure how it would,
how it would affect you,
you know,
I don't know if it would help you
nervous before the fight or not.
I don't,
I don't know how that would work.
see,
because it's an interesting argument
because on one hand I want you to take
it because I think that if it benefits
you as a person and is a,
is a drug that someone invented that has
a positive effect on your life and it
makes your life better,
then of course you should be on it.
I mean That's a good thing.
It's a good thing for some if something
comes along and gives you less anxiety
and you feel good and you're still
living a healthy life,
that's a good thing.
That's a positive thing.
But when it comes to performance,
like there's certain things like I know
the uh,
you know,
like adderall,
like fighters aren't allowed to fight on
adderall and some guys have
prescriptions for adderall.
Yeah.
But adderall.
Adderall is just speed.
The speed.
I mean look at the generic it was sold
but,
but for add guys,
is there any benefit to it?
Does it actually help them?
And it helps you study.
Add,
say you add real bad and you just can't
concentrate your spouse.
You can't read the book.
It will help you study,
you know what I mean?
But dudes,
they're fucking have a prescription for
adderall that aren't in school,
are full of shit.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
it is not a real doctor will tell you.
It is not a real fucking thing.
It's speed,
dude.
It giving you energy and you don't have
energy because of what happened.
So like guys,
I think that have adult prescriptions
that did fight mma.
It's because they do the train the train
harder than you're fucking jacked up.
Hitler invented or does not just affect
to meth or to make their soldiers
marched better and longer and unless
food.
So if You could be hopped up on that all
day long and train,
you know,
it'd probably be good.
You know,
it's,
it's interesting man.
I think that adderall is a weird one.
I've never done it.
But the people that do do it saY it's
fucking awesome for a bunch of different
shifts will snort it.
Yeah.
I mean chicks,
it's basically like,
it's like,
uh,
you're too proud to do meth.
You know what I mean?
Like that's drugs.
My doctor gives me this.
Oh yeah,
the doctor told you snort it,
motherfucker.
Talk to snort it.
You know what I mean?
Exactly.
Alright.
War,
machine,
war machine.
one 70 on twitter.
Follow him.
Go to his instagram as well.
Not safe for work.
Don't get kicked out of the cubicle.
Is war machine will show his dick?
No,
not no.
Not an instagram.
Twitter though,
right?
And my website to a alpha male shit.com.
And get bikes for shirts.
Buy I do alpha male shit.
Especially ladies go by.
That will be hilarious.
Take some pictures and send them to war
machine you with his shirt off?
I think it'd be cool.
And your next fight in bellator.
When can people watch you?
Is March 14th?
It's on spike tv.
It's in hammond,
Indiana.
Whereby chicago.
And is this the.
This is the beginning of the tournament.
70 tournament.
The tournament first round.
I got this guy named tom burrell.
A smash.
I do.
And hopefully if I drill rigs next.
Good luck to you brother.
Thank you.
It was fun talking to you man.
People enjoyed it too.
Alright,
follow war machine folks and thank you
to our sponsors.
Thanks to one 800 flowers.com.
Go to one 800 flowers.com.
Enter inj r e and get yourself a
fantastic offer of 18 beautiful
valentine's day roses for only 29 99 and
that is only for today,
February 12th.
If you missed the deadline,
you could still play some valentine's
day order by thursday,
February 13th,
but just hurry,
you could call them as well.
One 800 flowers and mentioned j r e.
Thank you also to squarespace.
Go to squarespace.com
and use the offer code joe to save
yourself some cash.
And thanks also to [inaudible] dot com.
That's o n n I t used the codeword rogan
and save 10 percent off any and all
settlements will be back tomorrow with
the one and only joey coco diaz.
Until then,
enjoy life.
My friends.
Much love big kiss.